YouTube site
well welcome everybody to the plans
committee meeting this new month first
of December sorry for the slight delay
but we've had trouble trying to get that
screen there working so we're going to
manage with this one and I'll probably
have a picnic the end of the meeting
this morning so
um welcome to everybody Welcome to those
who are watching this on uh notorious
YouTube channel
uh first of all I'll ask the officers
present uh and the account and the
committee present to introduce
themselves and I'll start off with
councilor Pennington at the back there
locally and popular
hi I'm Ruth craigie I representative
ly Richard Wiseman I represent the
Chevrolet Ward it will end up with golf
I will Norm good morning I'm at about
half award good morning my name is Pete
Christie I represent Biddeford North
good morning I'm Margaret Brown I've
Representatives good morning I'm Rose
Vlog and I represent two more two rivers
and three walls
good morning I'm Chris leather and I
represent Northern and then on my right
I'm Helen Smith planning manager at
Torrid Council
I mean I'm Stacey Dory I'm head of legal
governance good morning Chrissy leader
manager
good morning Tom Brownstone services
manager morning
[Music]
um
from highways mornings
that's everybody here at this point
Jackson we've got a full committee and
there's no fire drill that I know this
morning so if the alarm does go off the
warehouse is down the stairs the way we
came in please don't use the left
um
right well we'll move on with the agenda
now we've moved a couple of the
applications about but I'll mention
those when we get them
um let's write them one on the agenda is
apologies for absence
so we've had apologies from councilor
Watson and Pastor Pennington
substituting thank you
and item two on the agenda on pages 5 to
13 of that agenda is the minutes of our
previous meeting held on the 4th of
November I'll move those from the chair
well can I ask questions here I just
were accuracy democracy Banks there'd be
minute reported
I did raise an issue
um about
um
applications that have been caught in
the system
um thinking that you know what has been
two years tomorrow and Helen Smith
kindly gave a response and it's not
actually recorded in the minutes but I
would like to record it because it's an
integral part of Countryside issues that
we wouldn't face in the future I know
what you know any further than that it
was raised at the meeting and Helen did
give a very kind response at that
meeting as well
better reprise out because I can't
remember
yeah yeah we can look back and we can
certainly add that in yeah
thank you very much with that which will
be amended if it's relevant then to the
accuracy thank you for that I've moved
those minutes in terms of lock setting
them please hit the vote please
comes to Fountain at four
that's the brown boy
that's the Christine
that's the credit union
that's the Pennington four
councilor wise men or
no
that's good
um
H4 was when I met with all my extension
yeah okay uh item three on the agenda is
Declarations of Interest
and I think we all know this off by
heart but I'm reading this out for the
benefit of members of the public members
with interest to declare should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interests when the item is
being considered elected members of
Devon County Council and town and Parish
councils who've considered a planning
application by virtue of their
membership at that Council all the
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh and I
always add in here that it's only at
this meeting that the committee have all
the latest up-to-date facts on any given
application
um item four is uh agreement of agenda
between Parts one and two well there is
no part two
uh five on the agenda is urgent matters
information brought forward
nothing on there
item six on the agenda is uh important
that
all the important issues where I have
managed the committee of any prior
requests to speak nearby members of the
public and if we've got
for the first application at Sunny house
we've got one member of the public
speaking against
for the land at the Country Life
Cottages Westwood Hall we've got one
speaker in support
bow tied down Churchill way we've got
award cancer a parish councilor PDM
speaking we've got two members of the
public speaking against it
and we've also got us in support a
letter from uh somebody to be read out
from a Debbie Newcomb to be read out uh
who's the agent for that application
that's at Holland Park Farm winterland
Lane holsworthy uh counselor happel was
the board member
he sends something to be read out in his
absence
a statement
uh in support there's a member of the
public
to speak at that one and also in support
the applicant will speak on that one so
those are the speakers that are listed
or this Lawrence meeting
I always
public speaking at the plans committee I
always read out this a little bit that I
have written down
because it's expected that all who
attend the plans committee that they'll
give a fair and uninterrupted hearing to
the planning office of giving their
report and to all those listed to speak
and then to the planning committee
members when they begin their
consideration after all it is only
common courtesy thank you
and the Order of speakers is as follows
to any application the first will be the
planning officer who will give their
presentation of the application
and then any town or Parish counselor
who wishes to speak for or against an
application they have three minutes
and then up to two members of the public
who wish to speak for against the
application they have three minutes each
and then up to two members of the public
in support of an application
they have three minutes each as well and
then any storage council member from the
Ward
uh the application applies to in which
they've got no time limit they can speak
to it as well
and then after all that is when the
committee will then debate the
application
with any questions questions they may
have for the appropriate officer
I hope that's cleared out so not partly
right we move on then to item seven
which are planning applications now
um
we are moving application C is going to
be moved up into place of application B
because our planning officer delivering
both of those has to be awaiting at the
meeting so B will now be the third one c
will now be the second one which is it
uh Westward Hall one country life
Cottage is one will be moved up now
um the information
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports are correct at the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports will be provided in writing or
orally at the committee meeting
right well we'll move on to the first
application today which is application
7A and that's on pages 14 to 23 and
planning office Christian evenly will
give the presentation answer the
question
membership at Biddeford Town Council
there
thank you thank you German
um so this is an application of change
abuse is an office building and form
emergency accommodation which is use
plus eternity which is Nui
[Music]
um and change abuse of life is modular
housing units Energy Center have been
stored exactly so you know slow beans
there are a few updates so um this is
following third party representation and
also additional information uh shared so
um the policy requires that the proposal
Services reports would be and their team
it requires a Part B that it can be
demonstrated to appropriate marketing
that the site is no longer provides a
realistic Prospect of employment use
so we've uh there's been an additional
piece of marketing which shows that what
the value is how long it is being
marketed for and that the council has
actually had verified by a third-party
evaluation so
um and that forms the basis of
my opinion which is that the site has
been recently marketed for a long period
of time at an acceptable valuation
um both by representation claims the
sequential test has not been followed
um
a few things here so the sequential test
doesn't relate to marketing it
um so we don't expect people to Market
something and that they don't have plan
permission for so this sequential to
test certainly relates to what the
development is proposed
um this site is for
um a news class system right and you'll
see from broadbands in a minute that it
includes temporary combination actually
has an office and storage as well so you
can actually look at what's being
proposed and the plans there there is an
excuse that's anticipated that someone
can use the office to manage the
accommodation Etc
um
plus we consider as officers comprise of
the mixed use tests
um even
if members consider that the office is
so small that it's not a mixed use
um I would still recommend approval on
the basis that you could say there was
con it is contrary to the inverting
D however there is such a significant
need for this condition
that that would be a material
consideration so what I consider it does
mean with the impacting to be saying the
lines for your yourselves
um several seconds of that next slide
please
um so this is just first of it and
software so yeah it's quenched up and
different from marketing so the
marketing is required by PM 13B the
sequential test is required by Team 13 D
um and it's not anticipated that you
need to Market it sequentially it's part
it's the department applied for which
has to be considered sequentially
um and then so this um finally it's not
a
it's not a dwelling house which has been
applied for it's um
it's time for accommodation
um so in terms of conditioning use
it doesn't really need a success there's
no need to condition that the
development should be temporarily they
wouldn't be committed to anyway if we
start having people there as blacks
basically then that would require change
in its own right so it wouldn't be the
six tests that's required for a
condition
because it's simply not necessary
next slide please
this shows the site Sully house
um is on clubelli Road in Dutch people
would say and it's like by a member of
existing electrical uses the existing
use is adding topics next side
scenario photo of the site shows the
same thing but
um
more visually attractive I suppose next
slide
um so this shows office building
um so on the t-junction modular units
there to sort of Southwest and then
parking an existing parking area next
slide
thank you
this is the existing building changing
gears you can see on the top floor
there's uh the office I talked about as
well as the storage room
um and start facilities including toilet
and kitchenette and then second floor
and ground floor sorry personal ground
pool and this type of accommodation and
visual sort of what the modular units
would look like next slide
look like
um next slide
so it's just showing my bedroom internet
area and shower and living area next
slide
this shows boundary treatments
surrounding Sciences it's clearly
important that its type of development
is
secured and branch is well defined and
you'll see in the support that it's
considered that is the case and the
peace and Pioneers are not certain
objections slide
um this is just a visual in terms of
um the rising number of people in need
of temporary accommodation and this is
um in 21 22 it's a privacy of an
advising graph and it's news lately in
terms of the amount uh the councils have
been suspend on technical conversation
and the uh issue which is arising so
this is a considerable populated council
at the moment and it's shown mostly in
that graph next slide
this is um Sully house so it's an office
block at the moment
um
probably much more than I could say next
slide
this is from roadside I can see it's
surrounded by industrial unit systems
within
um participate
next slide
that's showing the same thing really no
need for me to explain next slide
oh
next slide please
so these are your main considerations
um as you see in my delegated report I'm
recommending approval
and I'll pass back to the chair to
introduce the speakers thank you very
much
thank you Christian
speaker this morning speaking against is
member of the public Rebecca Fernley
thank you
good morning once you're settled and I
got my
stopwatch here
you've got three minutes then to address
the committee template okay good morning
members um thank you for your time as
you know I normally speak in support
applications so this is the new
territory for me as well but um I'm the
only Innovation Court which is an
industrial building to the Northeast and
also speak on half of my tenants and
also Ben Braddock from Braddock's
Furnitures he's got an industrial
building
um in Stanley Court in the south east we
object to the proposal for a number of
the reasons and the officer has touched
on some of the points that I picked up
on in the application I think the key
point for consideration is your own
policy DM 13 that looks to safeguard
employment land
that I don't agree that the sequential
approach has been followed because I
don't think a small office
um shows a mixed use and the marketing
report has only been uploaded to the
website three days ago which is after
the officer made this recommendation
um I don't believe the mix of years
before being fully explored and
therefore it fails its sequential
approach I requested marketing
information it has now been uploaded
um but it doesn't detail any alternative
employment use it's looked at the policy
also states that the loss of employment
starts could negatively impact on
achieving your local plan objective and
it could undermine previous investment
in infrastructure in these areas it also
said that unless Society does not have a
prospect of re-employment but employment
reuse that changes will not be permitted
and this shouldn't be based on the
market fluctuations and the ability to
not let it at the moment so you
shouldn't be taking short-term decisions
on the basis of the loss of employment
loan and you know especially in all the
locality we need to safeguard employment
years
in addition to this we just feel the use
is completely in congress with the
surrounding business users the road is
called the Valley Road industrial estate
this doesn't make it sense it's suitable
for any form of housing is even
temporary there are health and safety
concerns that have been raised by our
tenants so one of our tenants is PJ's
couriers who starts at 4 30 in the
morning loading and turning the garage
using the turning head right outside
Sally house and we think that that for
that reason that policy dm21 looks like
they've got the immunity impact and
proposals and we don't believe that this
addresses this policy
in addition to this what amenity
proposals are there for proposed tenants
in this application where are the
children going to go I mean our
understanding is that temporary
accommodation in Torrance at the average
length of staying is up to two years
that's not very temporary to not have
appropriate facilities on the site and
I'm sure they're having officer can
provide comments on that
also my objection visit the application
is described as temporary use and the
officers commented on the fact that they
don't think that any kind of condition
needs to be so put upon this to control
this however
there's no detail in the application but
what this temporary use is and maybe the
officer can clarify this is the expected
length per say three months is it two
years because then we get into the
concern that if this is not transient
and temporary which is what the
Environmental Protection Officer is
often his consultation response on the
basis of are we going to get into the
statute of Gene use of this complaint
our tenants going to be able to complain
about the industrial activity that's
surrounding this site and
um and how that's going to affect how
they live in these times and that's why
we think that it's imperative that the
detail of the temporary nature of the
application is provided to allow them
committee to consider this properly
I want you to wind up no yes I've also
raised concerns about the application
transparency I don't want to dwell on
this this morning but there is quite a
lot of information that's missing I did
Freedom of Information request on the
pre-application inquiry and there's a
reference
um including within the application but
to be told that it doesn't actually
exist
um therefore I do understand the need
but my view is that this is an
inconceived quick fit with the lack of
robust information and if it's improved
approved it could be challenged and also
are we setting a Preston that this
change of use for other commercial
properties on the escape to allow for a
value residential use we urge you to
refuse this application and try and
Safeguard the employment use of this
industrial estate
thank you thank you
right that's the only speaker for this
application
um so I'll now open it to the committee
for discussion then
we'd like to start
president
yeah I'm not worried about this like
um a couple questions first the officer
can you explain your spiritual tests but
what are they it's just in lately
um so I just read it
from the policies the clearest way
um so it requires in all cases when
we're looking at an important site
a sequential test has been applied for
week Arrangement Side based on the
following order of preference
employment-based Redevelopment mixed use
including important translating
repellent
and then finally non-employment
generating so in other words when we
when we look at the plan application
um
and he's very describing it as a pub but
it's not particularly applicable because
it's that's not technically matters
policy but when we're looking at changes
of Hub which we've done quite a lot
lately
um you look at can they fit in a post
office in that Pub to make it more
viable Etc so the same the same would
apply to this can they have a mixed use
that still retains some of the problem
generating development but also has a
non-employment element to it so an
office would create an important
generating piece of development this has
an office in the building so there's no
definition of what an excuse is
um
you know it's a super use that we can
get some next Tuesday it's passing its
own right
um so from our point of view it's been
marketed since before 2020 at a
reasonable price the policy itself says
in the subtext
National policy determines that funding
policies should avoid the long-term
protection of employment sites where
there's no reasonable Prospect for the
site being used for our purpose the
example necessary to provide criteria
against which proposals for
non-employment development will be
assessment so in other words we don't
want to bother that course but the
science being there it's been advertised
for a long time at a reasonable price
we've got no takers
we can now look at different
developments
of view can it be used for next years
and then if it can't then the report it
cannabis is not important is that's kind
of appropriately I suppose to watching
yeah very much
um I'm gonna for those that we refuse to
segregation my reason if we're doing so
uh
at the moment the bit of it it might
have been is dying on its sweet
employment aspect of it is
critical at the moment you know we've
got shops closed therefore I understand
we're in a town center this is still
quite a bit different so we've got an
industrial it's industrial estate and we
should not be mixing residential Earth
and National talk and
I work in commercial I work in the end
construction as well the noise aspect
we're going to get the complaints from
Norway's coming through it's going to
affect the local businesses I can't
support a quick fix camera accommodation
for the authority although really do
need it but you look at a bit of an
issue yourself we've got so many hmos
within our within a bit of a center
itself is absolutely ridiculous that's
contributed to the downfall and benefit
of my opinion that's why I'm a pleasure
being a lot of casual opinion of it I
can't support this on the ground Reserve
fine I'll be nice to be like the Easter
should be on an industrial estate I'm a
safeguard of employment and actually in
future business growth in the area this
is going to actually
narrow the growth if I want to invest in
a bit if it look at this HMO snaps bang
in the middle
of industrial estate and I wanted to try
and carry his business going through I
look at that and go actually
I'm going to go to Barstool
that's right there's no might be in that
that's where the opportunities is going
to come from this Advanced area
we need to stand up for stories it
sounds great you put on heartstrings we
we all know that I'd be homeless last
year I was almost seven months you've
obviously couldn't help me actually got
too much money in savings but that's
ridiculous you have to spend your
savings then for going accommodation
to me refuse application against the M13
Safeguard employment bank I think Mrs uh
Bernie already touched around there I
mean it's a lot better speaking of what
I had about it passionate just common
sense approach for me I just don't feel
we can have it and communities if you
look at the community of these future
residents going into there
how you can how are you going to
safeguard them with all the noise of
employment
you can't do it and so that's your
children calling them now
I I don't I noticed like a bit of a born
so I know I just nothing against your
application what you do is it's all
fantastic
as we get paid to do you know you're
good at it but I kind of I can't read
that so it's my energy
thank you I'm not sure
I'm not sure if you want me to come back
please but I will be yeah I don't
require you thank you I'm just going
back to a person
you imagine they say about myself I've
been a committee thank you cancer
because
um I've been cancer Brown in there but
I'll just read out the
one about it's 13.87 in relation to
existing employment sites it's
considered that there should generally
be protected the sequential approach
will be taken to the ReUse of employment
sites development proposals for
non-employment uses will only be
supported on an employment side if it
can be demonstrated that firstly an
employment use and secondly a mixed-use
development generating some employment
is not achievable
so that is exactly what these sequential
test is uh councilor Brown yeah thank
you I want to be assured please that
every unit will have its own washing and
you know with bathroom facilities and
kitchen as you mentioned there's a
shower and kitchenette for the top okay
but does each unit have its own facility
or is it a multi-claim uh that's uh it
appears that um have its own kitchenette
bedroom
um and
um sort of living area but there are
some shared bathroom Department Services
there's a museum
I I would be quite concerned because
obviously you're gonna have maybe small
children going in there and they need
more than just that for every day usage
so I would go along with reviews and
second that we've used it because I
don't think this is going to be capable
of serving everybody's nature thank you
counselor
Council wise man then Council Christian
thank you thank you Chad
um I've got some reservations here as
well with mixed use I think it's a bit
of a breach the office is
totally to disturb the accommodation
units or not I'm not sure you can
strictly call that an excuse it would
only exist because of the accommodation
and we I think Trav that this makes me
think of traveling sites the suggestion
was put forward a few years ago that a
traveler site could be provided just
over the way just over the road there
and we were told at the time that that
wasn't suitable
um because you know it's not suitable
for for kids especially and for any kind
of residence to be in an industrial area
but that applies there and that would
apply here as well wouldn't it the first
reason I think I've been quite happy to
support
proposals thanks cancer Wiseman
councilor Christie thank you
um well when this first came up we've
got one old idea you know housing on an
industrial estate but of course we have
had one already in storage and
Torrington on hatchimal there's a
residential home
um are you think well that was on uh
also when you look at this estate
um
there is
another is that there is a house
Interstate right next door to the east
very close I'm not aware of any
complaints of being demand there's also
Adams Port which is on where he used to
live Mr chairman there's a smaller City
there between b m and middles there's
been no complaints from this uh them
about an industrial estate as far as I
know and so I think the the noise thing
is a bit overplayed in this picture
aspect
um
now
we're all aware I think that we we have
a problem in college
more explicitly and benefit about with
homeless people
and
we know uh how much is costing us it's
it really is inspiring upwards
and the councilor lock and I sit on a
budget working group we're trying to
save a thousand pound a year two
thousand pound there
and yet our housing costs are just going
through the roof
um there is a problem in the sense that
we have to have hostile we can't have
individual houses unfortunately because
of government legislation
uh our officers have searched for a long
time
for a suitable building in fact the
British trust offered the one that that
wasn't suitable
um they've been looking for a long time
and this is the only one we've been
apparently find
uh having said that of course there is
an issue
um one bit of a Town Council view CR
from him about the play Space
which we have brought up we were told
that well you know you've got the woods
at the back
not sure about that but I know a lot of
children who do play in them uh that's
the only thing that really I find
difficult on this but I don't have a
problem with this in the sense that we
have to be pragmatic yes we'd love it to
be just an industrial estate but it's
been marketed this building nobody's
taken it
it's an empty building remember which
adds to the empty building a bit of the
cancer of the goth referred to it and if
we can use it and we have to use it and
we're talking about people in Desperate
Straits
let's not forget that
um I can't see a problem with it it
sense and I I will propose to be
accepted
thank you Council Christian councilor
Pennington and then cancel it off well
thank you Sharon uh two point certainly
that's chair first of all about the
sequential test again
and also your slide that you could have
about our homeless and the need that's
in torrage I'm a little bit concerned
that we should be linked with two
because we may be accused or maybe of a
situation that we will pass this for our
own need rather than on planning Brands
I just wonder because you've got to sit
back to a test and you should go from as
I understand on the M13 professional
from offices
to Industrial and then the last resort
to residential as I understand the
sequential test from what you said and
thank you Council painting I'll just
then come and provide a little bit of
info on why by that slide so there was a
policy and it's time to get to the
content stage
so the need relates to I think it's st17
um so we do
okay one second
[Music]
foreign
Market requires us to provide a local
Enterprise housing market
in specific key references specialist
housing accommodation it says with
independent boundaries or the principal
corpse by assessments about exponent
boundaries proposals especially this
housing accommodation will be supported
where they meet and identify local need
so that we're saying there is a
significant need
the proportionate scale to be localities
so it's pretty much to reduce our
building
um but I can't say that they're
accessible to the facilities and they
provide necessary and civilian
facilities by the department that
complement effectively available
amenities so that's why that's in there
so
it's in there to cover off a specific
policy but that still leaves the
question that you've got to test the M13
first
because you can go to Industrial before
you build a residential
before dm17 kicks into place and I'm
just concerned that if you go and say
well we've got the m17 the remote pocket
we haven't proven the M13 and it's a
clash between auditory policies that we
need to be careful as a committee that
we are fulfilling so there will always
be some inherent crashes between
policies that's that's you know you
could remove the local plan and find
some wishes don't work with others
that's kind of the nature of the local
plan really
um so you could say it doesn't mean one
it needs to another and then we
recognize that it doesn't meet with that
policy but we give weight to the other
one which the material consideration now
I think it does mean the emperor team
it's clearly been advertised for a long
period of time with no take up so the
chances of it just remain in the day if
this was to be refused by the chance of
it being remaining is a vacant building
right it seems quite High it hasn't been
no one's wanted it as an office in two
years and it looks like it's before that
concerned how have you tried it yeah
I've tried it as an industrial to
protect or employ with them because one
of the issues in the new plan was it
always felt there wasn't enough
employment there compared to residential
development and I know that we're we're
ignoring that social issues here but
it's really very policy at the moment so
have we tested it on Industrial use
rather than office use so we test it on
um
[Music]
is very much set up as an office
um it would be very
um expensive to change that so it's been
quite an industrial building but the the
time employment relates to offices and
offices are an employment relating it
relates balance so it's completely
applicable
um while I've got the mic it might be
worth going through a few points if you
don't mind chairman on what
um just have written down the load
points on what moments have discussed
well I'd rather hear from the committee
and then you can bring them in in a
minute yeah the second point but very
briefly then just give me a good turn
here
um is it possible to put a temporary
allowance here on this application so
that you say the last resident comes in
in three years time so that it can come
back to to
the the uh office use that it was set
out so we are meeting a need I accept
the DM 13 and 17 New Market that case I
just wondered if it's possible the
condition in the last resident comes in
three years from the date and then that
office comes back into the employment
mix are we allowed to to to put a
temporary condition I say three years to
get this past and we can revise that in
three years time if we need to but again
it protects us from when we have an
emergency here that protects us I wonder
if that is a Way Forward
Ellen can you answer that please
I don't know if that's been considered
Chris has it
um well temporary use in other words
yeah so it would be almost
um
this is a business and respect foreign
use for this building then why would we
keep it we wanted to sell it and and get
that money back so I would say by virtue
or TDC pushing to buy and changing it if
it becomes if it becomes redundant for
its use
um I'm sure our property team will quite
quickly want to get rid of it as
an office building so yeah and we could
it would be better to put a condition on
rather than time we could put condition
on it which said something along the
lines of should there be uh should the
need for
um
separate accommodation cease then if the
building will convert to an office so
then it doesn't put time on it it just
says that if there's no longer a need
for it it's an office but who would
Define that mean
well I mean we would quite quickly know
in our housing team what the need is I
think
[Music]
all right okay thank you thank you
yeah so as as your officer has said I
mean in terms of temporary permissions
we would only put a temporary Timeless
limit on an exceptional circumstances I
think the alternative suggestion and the
sensible one it would tie in with the
Concentra and the M13
um and I think ultimately this is going
to be within the council's control it
will be operated by the council that
need will be demonstrated through our
housing options team
um there is that close link with our
planning team for the hand on property
team so there would be that ongoing
review of whether it's needed or not but
that certainly is a condition that could
be open to inclusion but I certainly
wouldn't encourage a specific time
time temporary period consent thank you
councilor you've been very patient
yeah I completely agree with councilor
Christie
um and I would second is motion to
approve the um application and I do like
well with the additional
um condition about preventing about
reversing I think that's a good idea
um it does something that we actually
need and I mean with regard to the
tenants you don't know whether they're
going to be there a month six months or
a year that's absolutely no selling so I
do think it's an opportunity and I would
recommend approval
before I bring councilman and The Goth
back in a minute it does say on page 16
at the top there although there is the
potential for an adverse impact on
immunity which is true and I think
that's something we've
had that well not highlighted it became
apparent when we had our site visit last
week but there is and that's what's been
raised by the speaker this morning in
the public too
um
it is it's not as straightforward
actually as you one thing it's when you
first look at it and councilor Brown's
points about the
washing facilities the bathroom
facilities in there I think you know
that's not been considered enough and
I'm in agreement with you on that that
we've got these pods that are supposed
to be set up outside
um they've got their own shower and
lavatory they've got everything but some
of these as it's been divided up inside
have not got their own bathroom
facilities and what does worry me about
this and it worried me at the site visit
when we're looking at it all is how
temporary is temporary
uh you've heard it could be up to two
possibly up to two years
I don't know what the terminal risk are
existing
um
uh properties we've got now that we've
got people in on a temporary basis but I
would actually think of people being
stuck in there for anything more than
about six months but when the six months
is up where would turrets move them to
him and there isn't there is an issue
with the immunity of the current
residence on the industrial estate
worried about their businesses worried
about the effect on them by complaints
from people living could be long quite
long term in these so it's not as
straightforward as it seems at first the
overriding issue is torrids have to be
seen in this plans committee have to be
seen to be dealing with this as they
would deal with any application from
anybody the fact that it's a storage
application is now the inner there the
fact that and cancer Christians made the
case we do have a need encourage to
house I believe we've got about 60
people is looking for temporary or
looking for accommodation I think it's
73 at the moment 73 and we've got 24
places currently and this will add to
that so there is that side of it but
we've got to look at it from all angles
which is what we're trying to do this
morning councilors
as I come back to we advertised this
couple years ago well we're still right
at Kobe's yet and was right in the heart
covered at the time I don't know which
business we want to come forward to at
least any property or buying a property
during period if that is me and it's the
uncertainty going through the economy
I'm one of the organize my money and not
investing so I don't agree with that
argument there at all but going back to
British business how long was the
advertise Bridge buildings as an
authority
this housing crisis hasn't come
overnight you didn't just wake up one
night and go actually today with housing
prices it's been going on for a long
long time being seen our budgets have
been going on at huge strains our
finances why wasn't British buildings
looked back properly at the time the gun
accommodation was provided a lot more
than eight units of accommodation going
through the heart of in the heart is a
bit of itself all hmos and hivas are
going into a bit of the same so it's
easier for Taurus to manage but that's
that's the main reasons a bit of his
fault with empty properties
unfortunately for us it's probably under
properties if you go to hires you alone
properties above I think that passive
roof training is done a detailed thing
on a John bit of tank and a certain
um you've done a group and you say
anything but the energy properties were
in the town it just highlight and showed
we have not
use Avenue there's an authority we
haven't gone down yet if this is a short
fix then it's not going to work
okay so I just don't know who would
invested
as a business two years ago in you know
the height of code itself so mine is the
employment language we're desperate for
employment without events orange there's
an authority we failed uh demand you
away that is employment man
we let that go we have not been but it's
residential we didn't then create the
employment Land from the residential
we're dead I noticed about application
but it's just
synopsis what's going on with famous
authorities
um
you've said you've got some points you'd
like to bring up in response to what
you've heard from the opinion thank you
Jack
um I've got a list that hopefully I can
go through with regards to noise so we
do have the environmental sessions here
so
um we've had getting that him up to
speak in terms of his comments and
statutory nuisance if you wish I'm being
told by our Environmental Protection
Team that there will be no exception as
a result of this so that's all I can go
by
um in my eyes that's acceptable we've
got John's team telling us this is fine
and there's no evidence to say that it
won't be so that's okay we've got the
highways we also have uh Mike lucum here
from highways
um and he's provided a comment as you
see saying that it's absolutely
acceptable in search Pilots there'll be
no reason diffuse application online
basis so and I would compare with that
is um you know it's been very good
question put parts to inform the site
and linking up to the Valley Road
um I can't obviously see any obvious
problems with it so massive car buy and
the access is great
with regards to
um amenity inside so we're talking about
um sort of shared total facilities
um
our our own housing teams absolutely
desperate for this they are are really
struggling to get people into this
accommodation bear in mind these are
people in some desperate housing need
and it is a temporary fix so it is
anticipated to be temporary
accommodation appreciate that you know
what they're going into might not be
their dream home but this isn't what
that's about this is about getting
someone off the streets of someone's
over and into secure safe accommodations
so and from my point of view the fact
that there may be share facilities
inspiring at our housing team are
telling us we need this we are really
struggling
um so that's all I can say regarding
that
and the play Space is an interesting one
so if this was
um so this is neither HMO or C3 housing
so it's more hostile
um if this was a house for a Housing
state board 20 houses that we need for a
park even if it was housing they would
be too small or would be allowing it's
like a bench they'd be a lap so be a
bench a tiny bit of glass and a bin
probably so there'll be no real play
Space there
um so whilst that would be great
um it is it is close to the Woodland
um children can play but again this is
just temporary accommodation in these
please as such
um
that's kind of all I had to say I think
we've kind of gone through the rest but
if you do want to hear from highways or
uh then
um by all means
um let me know and I'll get them to
stand
thank you Chris well we've got two
responses from Environmental Protection
Officer in the reports I think that
it's in the second response where they
mentioned about the potential
sort of an adverse impact on immunity
everybody's had a good say now so we'll
take the first proposition which was
counselor mcgoth that this is refused
uh seconded by councilor Brown could you
take that well we just need the reasons
for refusal just to clarify what the
reason is
the reasons afterwards can we do that
yeah
obviously and the policy loss of
employment I'm pretty sure you can now
say it as storage councils with white
then I know we challenging one another
but that's transparent yeah that's what
I really like about it
again
what you're voting for because I think
that and the question that we're going
into
for both the incoming and outgoing
and and amenity concerns as well yeah I
had raised no issues I always whatsoever
because I know it's got good right that
being employment reason
um
and then an amenity reason as well and
the facilities that councilor Brown
mentioned inside the actual building
when it's converted yes yes German
people might be desperate but they do
deserve a decent good place yeah so I've
always argued that same as affordable
housing just because it is for people in
desperate need it shouldn't be
downgraded in any way yeah
uh right so that's clear then so that's
an amenity reason and a conflict with
the employment quality reason the
amenity reason can bring in the
suitability of the accommodation
I don't remember's happy with that sure
if you've support refusal then you will
be voting for that
could you take them all please
councilor Christie the games
councilor craigie against councilor
leather against
cancel alarm against
councilman or Jesus
Council depending time
regretfully formed
that's no wise men or
that's four four and one two five
against
yeah
right so we'll never take the
substantial it's your motion or about
cancer Christie and certainly by cancer
lock
to approve the application with that
additional condition you would like the
conditions that would be the the use
would revert to yeah the office to use
class the use of lecture times the
because it's not the yeah the sewer
generous temporary accommodation and we
just checked answer Christie's Happy
Wheels yeah oh yeah
oh right could you take the vote into
approved
that's the Thousand four
that's the Brown okay
Christy or
that's the writing or Chancellor leather
poor councilor locks four
against
councilor Pennington against
councilor wise men yes
that's five four four against okay thank
you well you can see in members of the
public too and put those lots watching
this can see what a difficult decision
this has been really has been a
difficult not as straightforward as it
looks but I should be very angry and I'm
sure a lot of other members will be if
once this is up and running people are
living in there and start complaining
about the industrial uses in the area I
should be very angry about that and I do
hope that people are not stuck in these
uh
in the hostel for more than I would say
six months and it's up to tourists to
find suitable accommodation at the end
of the day but of course statins we have
a statutes in the house homeless people
um wasn't it easy decision that thank
you everybody thank you for that thank
you Chris
right we'll move on then now to our
second application which we're moving up
um
which we're moving up which is Agency 7c
on the agenda on pages 31 to 44 of your
agenda
and
implicit question was presenters
okay uh so this is for the change abuse
of a agricultural build uh for the
eruption of the dwelling
um the change of use of land for
basically Caravan side and the direction
of the store
um
next slide please updates
um so this site plan uh we can see the
red
application site and then to North there
are some Cotton Fields uh not speaking
produced with
um
[Music]
which happens
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no
um
there's
um contrary planting Etc download says
remove the trees on the side pattern and
so uh Wildflower
next slide
this is showing me some pictures of the
the side by side
again I'm going to have them nicely
there inside
the store and bottling Department slide
it's between constraints plan so the
trees have been removed and so hopefully
next slide
this is a proposed entrance to the side
or this is an existing entrance just
been writing them out a little bit
um and it's looking West so you've got
the trees there they're going to be
removed and uh that's sort of Crossing
where the house will be outside
to north
um
this is a way down and slightly B and
then
um
[Music]
that it is so a lot of that is just
retained landing and the source of
property approximately there in I think
they pulled down next slide
so this is just that back into the lane
um so it's like a little track that uh
it is onto pixel road so thanks so
Global track
um it's like Orchard Lane
this is uh visibility and it came up to
the norm and then next slide
this is visibility within the sound so
you can see
um we've got the highways officer in the
background there
is kind of imposing the photo and then
next uh this photo is taken from two
meters flat from the highest Edge so uh
and I think particularly
and then that's the visibility
certificate
[Music]
and there was some very bad
movement so
and then that's so that's why that is
next slide
agencies certain examples of pumpkins on
the highway next slide
these are making considerations pencil
of development part of appearance
Humanity biodiversity highways very much
Heritage and inclusion uh people know
that I recommended refusal on principal
and highways for instance I hope to the
speakers thank you chair
thank you Chris for that um Speedy
presentation of that application
right we've got um one speaker for this
and which is just in what suits the
agent for this so if you'd like to come
forward and speak right into the end of
that Microsoft days it in particular all
right
and once you settled you've got three
minutes to address the committee
thank you very much and thank you for
your time today
um the applicants Simon and Anna are
unable to attend at these are existing
events they've asked me to read through
a few key points which they've been
about Clarity into the queries rails as
many of you know Simon and Anna are well
known to the local Community Bank is a
family and living employer and they want
to stress they are seeking this
application for their family and their
business and they'll find out your game
[Music]
firstly with regard to the visibility
display the existing reduction this is
an area where the debt connection
between the vision to make implying or
not in our view and the highly authority
of employment free application you're
buying on things as well
over last year Junction and Road
alignment is acceptable when taking you
out of the tile back this is ultimately
an existing and improved Junction share
in another house that has been moving
safely to the back ends
with regards exactly concerns uh the
highways and we
have clarified to the case officer and
this site is before pamper bands only
means not coloring and he's Limited in
the election this would make Caravans
smaller than these region ranking
structure historically it's a big on the
hill with no notes of viable issues to
the highways the recent approval of
phase two was like nor2 for 399 on the
other side of the road with no
restrictions of access to peace Hill
shows that the highways Authority are
polluting happening the British world of
American significant populations
to discuss the current opinion regarding
10 often seasonal traditional Vehicles
has been consistent in our assessment of
the area
can you could you speak right into the
end of that right because some some of
the members of the public can't hear
very well do all that again no just go
back yeah back about five or six
sentences uh the reason approval of
phase two of cites annoy to the 300
levels with no restrictions of access to
pews Hill shows that the highways
Authority are clearly happened it's very
May accommodate the significant object
in the vehicle movement safely for all
Road users so you can spell the current
opinion going intent of the Season or
addition to Vehicles is being consistent
in their assessment of the area and it
automated the highways and raise no
issues over the access Associated
interestingly regretting
with regards to the news in conversation
with the police officer over the period
and we've appreciated the ability to do
so he has acknowledged very potential
need for the dwelling to support
assignment as the businesses that he
suggested that he didn't swap one of
their existing holiday lessons
the applicant cannot afford to lose
[Music]
stream with regards to the open market
brain as acknowledging the tax office
report the applicants are happy to tie
the plan to the site running their
required is a sustainable family home to
enable them to live on sites business
efficiently their families live and
considered four generations and maybe so
many years building up a business to
hand out future Generations
Simon and Anna do not require this
dwellings being open market and are
happy to sign an unilateralized table
with Target dwellings and business and
associated with that
as such we've submitted previously been
six months of imperialism providing a
precedent for allowing accommodation on
site to support traveling into resumes
we've taken Great Links through the
sustainable credentials of this proposal
invited the sources of the fighting to
have a glass while recognizing the power
of albatism again
policies consider the flexible working
practices such as local units to support
normal economies
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you for that
hmm
right that's hearing you speak it to to
the application
um
for me it is a tourism issue
and you see from the call then
that I called it in for
the reason that uh whether this is this
application supports a sustainable
enhancement to the tourism
sector and one of the issues to do with
sustainable which is a way word I
actually hate but one of the one of the
definitions of that this is of Economic
Development sustainability of Economic
Development
um I'm minded to approve this but I've
I've made a few notes
um
on tourism we've got a very brief policy
on sustainable tourism
but it's worth noting at the start of
this that definitely benefited from
hundreds of millions of pounds to spend
and there's over 11 000 jobs related in
the tourism industry in our area it is a
very important economic driver and
certainly a lot of the smaller rural
Enterprises that need support aren't
Keen at this council is seen wherever
possible to be able to support them and
I think we had one at Dalton a few weeks
ago and I think a small business and
they had a small house tied to the
business and I think this could easily
be achievable on this site I know this
area very well because I used to
regularly weekends books to pick up the
health and it's a very well used role I
mean there's one objective comes from
the current proprietor of the pig on the
hill says is it he is a very busy
business when it's operated and it is
and there's lots of traffic they have
special events up there so the issue of
the lane pubes on the road itself for me
is addressed there are plenty of passing
places in it and the technical note that
they've had done uh that says that but
I'm going to leave it to hear the views
of the committee whoever councilor
Wiseman thank you chair oh just a couple
of things really
um I'd like a bit more clarity Clarity
on the access because not that more than
one access now
but also we're not planning on planning
terms is it possible to restrict things
to counterbatch is that a definition
you know I've got some experience of
Caravans and so important we'd sometimes
get a camper van alive that is the size
of a coach
so you know could you off without this
uh thank you Mr Wiseman so there's
there's one access uh coming into this
site which is
um sort of along that Bottom Road
um
so it comes you come up a piece of road
or down a piece of road and then it's
the one at the very start and then so
that that's the access there and when it
comes again so that's the one access
um
[Music]
[Music]
it's not the issue of visibility isn't
off this small Lane yeah I think it's
the next bit along so that's where
there's a problem
um I I would um incur that it would not
be possible to condition that is only is
the capital ads for a variety of reasons
um one very renewable uh issue of what
is a campaign and what's a camera van
um
foreign
but I think the agent is clarified what
I've picked out because the agent said
hey email the 15th of the July stated
that the application is for an open
market house but then on the plannable
there's a ledger at the applicant estate
of the 14th of October stated that they
would be happy for the house to be tied
to the business I think that is an
advantage
um but I have more concerns about the
storage building
um the brewery aspect of it because
again in the letter but the applicant so
you state that they bottle around 10
hours every three two to three weeks and
it's done by gravity not by Electric
um
but there's no information on there
websites about their Brewery but if you
go on visit Devon and you go into
um the brewery website it says
um
the country live Brewery They produced
up to 15 000 pints per week and are
currently the largest Brewery in North
Devon and they're based at the big sheep
so but I don't know how old that
information is
yeah it's not as I understand it the
bottling is separate from the the cakes
that they fill which they fill at the
big sheep and get delivered from the big
sheep is what I understand right so they
so it is only bottle in the the bottle
of limited amount I think according to
their yeah
so my last point is about the access I
mean that the applicants shown that the
extra land required for the visibility
is it in their ownership yeah because I
understood that you couldn't have
visibilities plays if you know if you
didn't own the land
well in in the pre-application I read
the pre-application which is referred to
in there
uh high-risk technical note that they've
had put together by
um
by a company we've looked at the aspects
of the highway and and that
they've said
in the pre-application the access was
agreed providing you can provide the
visibilities place and it occurred to me
why that wasn't pursued with the
application yeah thank you chair so um
we're talking about on the right they
should come out of Ratchet Lane
entrepreneur on the right I thought that
farmer is written in support of the
application yeah so the um the
applicants don't have ownership of the
visibility display which is quiet
um so in other words this was approved
it could create a potential causing
problem because what would be
conditioning is a visibility that's
never achievable
conceptual photo
um the Hedge in the winter cut back is
significantly less than this phase which
they've said they can provide
um
that hedge is in the farmers ownership
the Anthony's have said you know oh we
can buy and switches around off the farm
and provider gigabits for the display I
have advice that I'd be into a broad
scheme come back in with different Red
Line uh certifying the difference
certificate because you've got different
ownership there and then we big
condition up at the moment
the applicants cannot provide the
visibility which is required and you'll
see quality boots between the receiver
on spider that is
um personal issue
and can't considered physically
if it was if it was approved on this it
could be a condition that they've got to
provide that visibility no why because
it's not impossible
[Music]
yeah a couple of points um which is
awesome I was told there's an existing
business
and yet they don't own a pig on the hill
where is the cottage business The
Cottages did that so that's the bit on
the right is it
um yeah
so there's there's Portugues here yeah
you can see those so that that
consistent business
um so they own a holiday Cottage
business now I do feel the need to
clarify this because
um
but effectively they've come in for an
open market dwelling and the sort of 10
power when it's looking like well that's
that might be a problem they've said oh
we'll tie it is some appeal decisions
now that's not how it works if you want
to consider the n28 real work is
accommodation and tie it then we would
need the information on them in order to
tie it so you cannot tie it but the
problem is here they haven't
demonstrated that the business is
economically viable they've given us
nothing they haven't shown us what the
need is but if it's so if they were to
come back in with that and and
visibility displays Etc then we may be
able to do sort it will
um frankly at the minute there's no
information
on those system business in order to
enable us to consider that policy so
they're actually living on the site that
they're existing business aren't they I
understand we do not live on site or we
may do but but my saying was that all of
the units their holiday that's
um so my argument was it wasn't an
argument as part of the planning process
um we'll we'll always try and get out
the patients um across the line but also
be possible actually work as a local
Power Team we have some of the highest
people votes in Southwest which I think
personally as well
um now
um the
what I have explained happened is you
know at the moment this is an acceptable
if you can do this this or this if you
can provide more info on the business or
you can maybe reuse one of those
buildings and provide it elsewhere or so
I've tried to be flexible but instead
they've said actually we're just want
you to consider this which is fine
that's their right
back yeah
is it just me or do we get one of these
supervisory dwellings every time we come
to a meeting there it seems and they're
always problematic
um my my issue with this one is
it's trying to be anyone could come
along like the barn near agricultural
field so I'm going to put 10 Caravans on
it and by the way can I have a permit in
the house
that's how it seems to be and the
permanent housing one isn't very well
related to the Handler the size I can
see
um it's a chicken and egg isn't it
because whenever these ones come up
the supervisory housing is there for an
existing business this is one where they
say oh we need it and we'll have the
business as well and I it doesn't sit
very well with me the one we had last
meeting at Heartland there was an
existing business and I wasn't too happy
about that but you can see why they need
it and they explained and they gave us
you know what the business was doing
this one seems very speculative or we're
gonna put some Caravans there but can we
have a perm in the house in the middle
of the countryside which is what it is
um so I'm not too happy with that
well I tend to agree with the officer we
need more detail and we need
a real explanation of why they need this
house the um it is an existing build
business the holiday Cottage isn't a
part of country life
it is this is an extension expansion of
their current holiday letting business
as I understand it from what they've
written in
the whole site with the pig on the hill
and the Cottages to let the pig on the
Hill's got
um holiday accommodation that they've
built on that site
and across the road on the right hand
side there that also is holiday that's
separate from this business but that is
also holiday let's so that whole little
context if you like Sean there is all to
do with tourism and holiday lets and it
is in existing they're not just starting
a business up by wanting 10 sites it is
an existing and there's a swimming pool
involved too which if that was
um if they were living on site to manage
the whole thing would be a far better
proposition than them having to travel
from away now to look after it all and
but again when you look just up pews
along the right and you can't see it
from that I don't know if you've got a
block plan
you've got this huge estate that we gave
outline planning to
the last meeting I think it was up on
the right that field it's very light on
the right hand side going up now in the
report it mentions
possible traffic from that when it's
developed coming down to yourself well
I'm very unfair to put that in to do
with this application I was not very
happy when I read that because it's
completely separate from this
application but it was to me trying to
overhead the pudding as far as crucial
roads concerned it is used by
Refugee story goes up there and they've
never had any problem I asked by a
manager of that if there's ever been a
problem going up there with a refugee
from the thousand so
I've taken it on board what Chris had
said about
um if they need more actual evidence of
what the business does in a financial
way
that um
you know I really think we should be
supporting tourism and small family
businesses that want to increased they
do employ there would be two people
besides the two applicants before people
employed on that side
um you know I'm I'm in bed of supporting
the applications they can provide the
access
what gets me is looking at the
pre-application inquiry
they've said in there that it could
provide and the officers accepted that
display could be provided from Orchard
Lane onto Google
why haven't their officers said well
look you need to come forward with this
if we want it to be considered in a
mountain yeah that's enough for me for a
minute casting a goal
I'm sorry I could see the highways are
absolutely itching over there
I'm chairing this
but I would like to get highways in the
Hop season he's just gonna ask me
questions and go back to the the slide
down the vicious papers
as and where as long as I've said I'm
glad it's not very long but as long as
I've sat on it I've never seen such a
detailed thing about a vision display
but he's like measure and stick out for
him and his nice selfie picture in there
enough in there I've never seen that
before so Michael obviously but get that
cool thank you
right turn and just turn left and
so
can I can I rewind if it's okay because
I just want that there was a couple
points I picked up in the gentleman they
spoke on the behalf of it and I just
addressed a couple of those issues
please to start with and I'll come on
tonight just and I think you've
mentioned it as well with regards to
Priya we are given details of
applications and for example visibility
to Slaves would say yes that's
acceptable if you can achieve them it is
going to be able to achieve them so in
other words actually a few compromises
were given
um such as because it's a single Track
Road primarily you know rather than have
the Asylum near side Asia carriageway we
accepted or I accept their Center of
carriage away so it's very much yeah
yeah it likes it that's that's a visibly
suppose we want for release you're
offering if you can provide it that's
fine okay so that's the word is
um the a couple people mentioned about
the gentleman as you also mentioned um
about phase two
and
um I I wasn't quite sure I didn't quite
catch what he said I think I'll say that
I couldn't quite hear him saying I
wasn't sure if he was meaning that it
was there is talk about
um accusing Road or the bottom with it
can be used as
a construction access for
um for that foraging House Development
or they're about or whether he was
talking about the development principle
that in casually said all sorts of
concern what was the one it was made I
didn't hear what I didn't hear any
concern right but it's the German that
raise that is they generally raise the
right it should be discussing the last
slide at the top in this application
okay right sorry yeah because I think
that's in your report now yeah it is
yeah yeah okay so just come back then
um with regards to the additional
traffic flows again my understanding is
well I mean certainly you look at
existing traffic flows wherever they are
we also have to look at and with any
application for example roundabouts or
whatever we look at likely increases
over the next X amount of years
um and clearly there'll be organic
growth plus the 400 house development
that's going to be sure it's the east of
that now what the applicants agent did
was went away looked effectively their
transport statement I'll talk about the
400 pounds and just effectively took out
of that which is a perfectly fine way of
doing it took out the fact that there
will be an increase from that um road so
I think we have to take that into
consideration
um and the other point is uh again I'm
quite catch what we've said about even
more times and Caravans I mean the
application you've got to specifically
say Caravans are motorhome so I was
working on that basis and I didn't know
I was going to ask Chris again about
whether um the science could be a
particular conditions okay
um sorry sorry guys
yeah let's stay back in there there
would be the size of it if you're a
gravity condition yeah but in order to
be put in place for the size of vehicle
going up the length
there's a restriction to learn from the
vehicle but then you would yeah that's
the way uh just trying to yeah it's not
bad chat but then you'd be stopping pin
orientation and goodness knows what else
that's when it becomes difficult and
then you're going to put it down for
Access then of course even turn around
and say I'm accessing something it's
incredibly difficult in Focus so
understand what I'm saying that would be
um
yeah it's quite a difficult way I'm not
even sure it would be impossible to be
honest
because of race objections can I just go
through those very quickly I was going
to ask you anyway again thank you sorry
Mr I mean if I said who were you I can
ask it
so effectively I raised two issues okay
one of them is found in both effectively
comes down to the wording of the
national planning policy framework which
is that an application that supervised
saving suitable access for all Road
users okay so so the two books I raised
was one about the visibility and I think
Chris alluded to it if they could get
the land off the adjacent land own it
will get some agreement we have a
different conversation right now that
person wouldn't be an issue
[Music]
um
but like I said as it stands at the
moment they can't achieve what um is
being offered that's that's the bottom
line as we see it I've even met the
applicants um agent outside and you know
we've gone through it I've also taken
the topographical survey and like I said
I just can't make it work and like I
said the the simple fits here is if they
had access to that
um adjacent land then when I say the
conversation differ
the second one and I've taken questions
at the end of that one if you want the
second one was about
um the actual Access Road itself
um and I'm talking because if you can
access this site it's either going to be
from corporate road to the North or it's
going to be for Peugeot across to the
South
either way it's about 550 meters each
um I the concerns I raised with either
limited passing opportunities and I
appreciate what you're saying that in a
car passing another car is actually
fairly straightforward okay and that's
two points here number one you're
relying on private land uh for example
field entrances
um
and although
obviously including myself and everyone
else in this room we all use informed
private land is passing places
um for when when we're traveling on
country lanes and the question is can
you rely on those for a planning
application
and consistently I've always said no
whenever I looked at an application okay
secondly we're not talking about cars
we're talking about the nature of the
vehicles that this is going to be
attracting such as Caravans and such as
motorhomes and I've been out there and I
took the technical note in the map that
was given in that and I parked my car as
readily as I can I quite like the paint
job on my car so you know like I said I
I thought I was fair and I've measured a
lot of those passing bases and they're
not achievable for larger vehicles okay
so therefore the amount of passing
places you've got isn't quite as high as
a sound and to be honest sorry about
digressing now but in the old days as
part of um the uh the um the site the
site visits we would have gone out it
would be a lot easier to see it's
quality I appreciate you know we don't
do that now and I'm just going to say
the Google Maps
doesn't quite paint the same picture as
what's on the ground
so there are all these living surprising
opportunities you've got large Vehicles
potentially having a reverse quite long
distances and that's in the mix with the
fact that cusill road from my
observations is fairly well used by
local Road users for example Amateur
Road six is bisected by pews of ground
on my on the visits I've seen I've seen
pedestrians like wild Walkers
um I've seen cyclists I've seen Runners
and that was my photo of the the lady on
Boris who um kind of grew me quite I've
made the stable radio jacket wasn't when
I was outside YouTube
quite often so so that's the problem
I've got in so far as whether advice
even simple access you're introducing
larger vehicles to a site
where you've got a minute survival
values is
um that and like I said with guys at the
lady on the horse apparently you can't
get the silly things in Reverse so it's
not quite as easy as it sounds
great
um Michael could I just stop me and ask
you this yes what about the vehicles
that currently Supply the pig on the
hill
what about the delivery vehicles that
currently grow up there yeah absolutely
and we are well we've got broad issues
by large Vehicles anywhere I agree and
we are where we are but for the point is
there's the applicant restricted it
through Camper vans
in transit size camper ones not the huge
Winnebago things then that would
although you could get one up there but
I doubt anybody would go up there and if
this was approved
with these 10 Caravan camping sites yeah
then the the owners of the business
would surely be saying to any potential
customers don't come here with something
that's one of these huge things it's not
suitable for that but can you condition
it with an EXO if you would say no but
I'm just saying overall yeah you you
were making assumptions as well as I am
yeah about how it could operate and how
it may operate absolutely but unless it
is it's um how we secure that and maybe
the 400 sites that have been approved
outline if traffic from there starts to
use abuser Road I think most of the
wrong Corner Road and through onto
bottle but but some unders it will come
down there yeah when they come in with
the reserve Master's application it may
be they've got to contribute to
Improvement of peers and Rule if that's
felt to be necessary I agree the only
thing we'll say about that and we are
digressing but
um the highways are a lot of land down
there I take practice area I spoke to
our asset management team we just don't
own a lot of Highway rights over a lot
of land down there because in in this
particular area
sorry in this particular area there are
quite a few passing bases quite short
space it's it's further out you know
it's from just beyond the settlements to
Congo Road and vice versa that we have a
problem
um but yeah I mean if for example they
were talking about
um tent pitchings where where you rarely
bring your car then we've been again
we've been having a different
conversation right now
um but like it's the nature of the
vehicle that's a problem so all right
thank you for that foreign
to survive in this economic
and you know understanding is over in
that so I'm in full support of it but
I'd like to defer the application that
gives the applicant then the chance to
go back to the landowner for the vision
display and hopefully then make on some
agreement with that I didn't see it be
squashed right now because
tourism business employee around the
area
color support
Chris thank you I've never been casually
looking I I I'm also trying to work
through the problems here I really am
um that I couldn't prefer for that
reason because the applicant would have
to withdraw the application and resubmit
which I've discussed with the Aging
about it if they can get better bids Etc
and maybe change the nature of
accommodation so sending cars so even if
they have some permanent of encourage
there fine but the nature and the
business change now that would require a
new application because the change in
the red line the changing land ownership
Etc so you may wish to indicate that you
could support a decision that's fine it
may not even need to come to community
um but I don't consider we could defer
it because as soon as the committee ends
and they're deploying the agent is
saying
I can't accept these changes
the vision display that needs it to be
withdraw and effectively because they
they need to get that red line changed
so if we go back can we go back that
slide again which size
um there's one where you come out
obviously here now is you could come at
eight when yeah
it's obviously dead tight there is there
no way of trying back that hedge Road
as far as you're going to get it um
unless you're going to kill the Hedgehog
um
yeah I said that's that's that's it
that's pretty well maintained right now
well I went working with different
opinion though I wouldn't kind of say
that once but I'm not an expert like you
but the same but I'm saying is this work
being on site sometimes showing a
different picture and a consumer that
wouldn't go on site
all right thank you thank you can have
been Council looking I was just going to
suggest and so you think it's getting to
the goals that the application is to
deferred so that they can sort out the
ownership of the visibility display and
come back with the supervisory dwell in
the business but I understand now that
that is not possible
yeah can I can I come in that I think
that level of change to be application
you can go beyond what the police
officer has just described to that thing
he would necessitate a new application a
change in the red line would necessitate
a new occupation
um I think we would reference earlier I
think from the chair whether a condition
could be used to require the visibility
today now it is possible to put a
condition on a permission requiring
something to happen outside of the red
line before development can commence or
come into use however we can only do
that if there is a reasonable Prospect
and we have knowledge that that can be
achievable and my understanding is from
what the case officer is that there's no
certainty that that can be achieved so
again I don't feel that a condition
would get around it either only that the
land or the farmer who runs that
is written in support of the application
so so you know that's what made me think
well
if we put a condition on that they've
got to achieve that to get the app and
get the application without
support already in writing it's it's
only important from the family rooms
yeah so it just wouldn't work so we'd
only condition something in the blue
line or in highways like or on highways
land eventually so we we're never going
to condition something on third party
land that is called partly outpatient it
needs to have a stick with it and you
want the red line to include the holiday
country
no no so the red line doesn't need to
include the holiday Cottages but what
they would need to do well I mean if the
issue is that this is an extension that
expansion of exists in business the
holiday Cottages are part of this
business so there's not just as
councilor Christie said 10 campervan
sites stop there and uh Supermarket
adren for 10 cameras yeah so it's a far
more in-depth when you read all the
documentation far more to it than that
yeah they want to put the you know so
you know the fact that they want to put
this Barn there to store some of the
ground's maintenance equipment and do
hand bottling of a certain because
they've got the unit now recording the
on Crivelli Road I think it is that
actually they don't need to paying quite
a lot of money for that this would again
help support the business that they
could do this it is all tied together in
the consideration is committed has got
to me and whether they would approve to
someone they take your point and but the
so we don't have to change the red line
and we can stay in the dream right now
but we've got more information on that
we don't have that holiday business so
we don't have any information on the
existing business so when we considering
workers accommodation or combination
applied we'd need information to show
this is what the business generates per
year is economically viable this is what
it generates in terms of employment use
so there is actually need for dwelling
Etc this is where the existing dwelling
is for example so we uh it's not working
for these reasons so they need to flesh
out
why they need real working slowly which
will enable us to then Target without
that info the condition just wouldn't be
related related to the application and
we couldn't consider the policy the
answer could you just resubmit with that
information I mean that's that's
certainly what we encourage we're
encouraging them to withdraw the scheme
and change the red line improve the
access and and provide more information
in terms of the business Etc
you know I go even further and say they
can provide Shepherd Hudson site or
something like that to a minimum scale
instead of something which requires you
target tow it or is incredibly large
then that would be incredible result
because it overcomes the main issue if
we go to the aerial Plato
yeah
so this stretch appear
that bit and then this stretch here and
that bit that's the main issue right
in terms of passing 30 cents now
if you remove the larger Vehicles this
new consists said
um it caused some possible reasonably
the car can pop the car more easily the
issue is introducible
so if the nature of hollow accommodation
change as well then in my eyes are sort
of knocking down the three reasons for
refusal so that and so there is a
solution it's just it needs the new
application
a free submission
I mean because I don't want to cancel I
don't want to if this is refused in its
current form I don't want them to have
to spend a fortune again putting a fresh
application and if all we need is or in
all the planning office need is certain
information
that would enable us to consider it and
in the light of a tide dwell into an
established businesses expanding because
I am and I'm sure most elected members
of tourist Council really do want to be
seen to supporting tourism in our area
wherever they can an expansion
particularly live small businesses we've
got a real problem with lack of camper
van spaces people are parking in the
streets in Ecuador in the center it is
it is a cyclical business as well most
of the business with a physician in
these winter terms it is in the city
although I'm big support of all around
tourism canceled it up yeah there's
nothing to everything that everyone says
um and I do support ruin industry
um but I would recommend reviews with
this application as per the officer's
report that would very much look forward
to the applicants put it in a fresh
application covering the red line issue
that
um visibility display and more
information why they need to
significantly dwell it and I think that
would be the best way forward they get a
free application
can I just come in there
it's been a really interesting
discussion actually and I think the the
way you're looking for Solutions is what
we officers do in a daily basis and I
hope it's clear from the office's
presentation that that is what we very
much want to do on this application but
cancer looks recommendation it's
absolutely the right thing to do we
can't we as a committee you have to make
a decision either approve or refuse I
think a deferral to suggest it's
withdrawnism within the remit of the
power before you so
um just to clarify that that chair thank
you Helen
Council Pennington and then we we're
going to go to the boat then on this I
can share
um just interesting one of the very
first pages of the presentation it
appears to me you've got three different
applications composite it into one and
that in itself raises just questions
about the application but I won't be
late because you had a good discussion
and I want to be really clear when you
come to the vote the house now is not
open market the house is actually tied
to the camp about the situation
will I just be clear where I'm coming to
the local here because I don't want to
see an open market house on the site
because that I think is going to be the
maker of breaker for his way above in a
minute and I want to support businesses
you know we were businesses and and I
may want to declare across Warcraft
because we want to see a vibrant
porridge
um particularly as Chuck's field car
fire that no longer takes Capital
balance over as well there is a real
Market given the number of capital bands
made to be introduced
um and sold in the country since
corporates broken out so there is a
undoubtedly a market in that direction
but I I just want to make sure that the
house development Chris is is tied to
the development and can't be civil
separately in the labor stage
yeah okay well that would be if this is
turned down today and they come back
with a resubmission with the information
that Chris is alluded to
that will be in with that yeah
this is a supervisory dwelling or a
workers dwelling to run the site manage
the site that will be in absolutely
that would be a different proposal
and that's where this extra information
on the viability of the whole site that
they own cottages and watch the balls
that's where that information will come
in yeah thank you chair thank you
right thank you it's going to look good
outside
um on reviews in this application I
would like the agent to go back and say
that we do some support
in principle what they are trying to do
to improve their business yeah and I
look forward to a favorable
application coming in that's what's new
yeah thanks for that Council as well
right it's been proposed by Council not
certainly by cancer crested that we
refuse this application
uh could you tell them please
councilor Christie
councilor craigie for the councilor
leather and abstaining from this because
I want to see another application come
in
so
foreign
[Music]
thank you
um
understanding
meaning
thank you
spotlight
s
[Music]
thank you
um
education uh
B which we put down to three so it's 7B
now which is change of views from
uh plus to an accommodation then at the
still world and Angelo you're giving us
this presentation
thank you chair
[Music]
um
through the change of use of novice to
our Hospital accommodation number four
Hudson Road and Maple Grove yeah before
committee as forest district council
will own the property and now I've been
applicants and assistance uh just to
providing verbal updates I have noted an
error in Watson's report and to have by
the accommodation will be seeking to use
the temporary Converses as you know the
housing departments
um five weeks
it's right before we showed the location
of the site
um seeing the western side is a uh
International cycle of um car garage and
to the South is
South as a shipyard and to the east is
the bishop dock and uh need the
properties and to the North or it's a
Terrace
um tennis building which has a
residential property with the automatic
existing and to the center of that
building made by
um was formed include by a committee in
2020 for the change is used for my
office to the hostel accommodation and a
key part of the consideration is this
application to function in connection
number five because there's an internal
um link on the ground for the right
first floor
and have two plans that's available next
slide please
it says principal renovation the yellow
property is number three published Stone
which is uh independent club party
residential property and the middle one
is number four and to the right-hand
side is number five which has that
information to be used for hostel
accommodation
next slide please
here is the silent elevation of the
property as you go to the car park which
is where the fishing box is
next slide please
here shows the real information we have
that Terrace building with the outside
the minty area apparently there
and the arrangement that's why it's
self-explanatory
next slide please
here shows the proposed floor plans uh
outlining red is number four which will
be to provide two uh family size uh
units that will have a kitchen episode
here and shared um Sharon means in space
together with uh storage on the ground
floor as well as the Upper Floor or the
advanced storage in terms of cleaning
facilities and other facilities to
manage the property
number five is to the left that's
prepared to Beacon uh converted in
conjunction with this to be three
um you might sell content uh units of
recommendation
and like us uh already mentioned there
is um internal links to the property on
the ground floor as well as the first
floor and it will be this proposed to be
served or punching the Practical terms
outside the application that has one
unit of possible interest
um Powers the um they desperately will
have um temporary combination
next slide please
of material considerations it is noted
within the officer's report there is a
conflict with policy PM per team
nonetheless taking into the balance of
this decision before you the material
considerations is that the the
identified need for temporary housing
that has been evidence and thus what is
well into the balance of providing an
accommodation in conjunction with their
previous approval and the site will
provide
um
uh units of potential accommodation and
it's effects on residential Lindsay as
we sort of discuss the accommodation
will be for a temporary basis and
therefore uh comments from environmental
health do not consider there to be being
obviously compartment in terms of
surrounding operational businesses
um in existing neighboring property to
safeguard their agency hours of
construction in terms of internal work
so that's also to know there is no
external works it's all internal
encounters will be
controlled by a financial commission and
the design as I mentioned there isn't
any major any internal works it's all
internal renovation quality there's no
harmless results of the skin and highly
impacts is considered to be a minimal
considering it was an office to change
into those accommodation and the
recommendation that the scheme is
improves not quite a vaccine chairman
thank you Angelo there's no speakers to
this one so
I'll throw it on to the committee for
debate Council yeah I see that Northern
Town Council recommend approval there's
no objections from major consulties or
any neighbors so I would recommend
approve was but the officers report
thank you
hello
yeah there's that we've already got one
Hospital accommodation next door so
nobody else want to comment on that
okay we'll go to the bank and things
that's about it
that's the ground floor that's the
question for
that's been crazy oh
yeah that's no leather sure against
the Pennington four
councilor Wiseman or
thanks for one against today thank you
I will move on to our next application
and we're back on the agendas published
now which is 7D on pages 45 to 56 of
your agenda
and
Angelo's taking this long as well sorry
you know
right now
so the application before the seeks is
subdivision of an existing Wellington
State high reported in Northern Parish
Northern off Junction and the
application was called to planners
connected by councilman and it's even
their oxygen report sighting the exact
wording that's in relation to Heritage
grounds and San Antonio and
and designated Heritage asset has been
identified through the application
process
um following the preparation of the
committee reports
um a third-party representation was
received that providing additional
Heritage information about requested the
building should be listed the
conservation afterwards consulted and
considered the key features of the
building will be preserved in the
current scheme and therefore the
building is not considered at risk for
the current or the council to Warrant
pursue in their listing
so please
so before you use the location plan and
showing the accessible Valley corner to
the left-hand side of the screen all the
way down
um public foot off number six Northern
and then the site is to the far right of
the slide which is outlined and read the
extent of the existing site Associated
to the dwelling
next slide please
here sends you an existing site plan of
the existing books of the existing built
form which is um will be Illustrated for
the slides that comprise of uh a larger
dwelling that is historic Origins have
evolved over time we've been a
subsequent Annex that is no longer used
as an Annex and has been
um linked to the main dwelling through
extensions which will be shown to the
slides subsequently thank you next slide
so here is the current site access
um down on the corner of Bloody Jack
um bloody Corner Junction and to the
public footpath that serves a number of
existing dwellings including the site
next slide please
here before we show so this the
visibility play to the access site
so before we use a principal elevation
so the left hand side is what is
considered the more origins or the main
dwelling with the historic features and
to the right hand side is
um
that are part of the Annex Building with
the garage
next slide please
so before you share those part of that
principal Innovation as well as the
Riverside elevation that is identified
through
um The Heritage statements to have the
best key features historic features of
Merit that would have originally have
been a part of the Keen principal
renovation preserved to animals Society
in relation to its um relationship to
the river and that was what would be
seen
next slide please
before you shows uh on the left hand
side is that rear elevation which you
can see the different built forms have
evolved over time and to the right hand
side you can see the flat brief links
which are all the constructed and it's
high in that one that will form into the
other
and uh below to the left is take an
average um from the tennis court that
serves a dwelling next slide please
he just said she moves out towards
yesterday from within the site and
ground drops away from the boundary down
onto the Southwest coast part and
started bounded by the park as well next
slide please
it says you they mean space of the real
elevation from the immunity area of the
annexable points neutrality will be I
mean
inside and the left hand the image shows
you
um The Wider context of the immunity
space that was served at the proposed
new dwelling and then to the right is
the access which is the public park as
well shed
next slide please
uh here's an aerial image that shows the
the evolution of the sites as you can
see the different uh built walls
distinguish and also it shows the
Flatwood mix between uh the original
main dwelling as well as the former
Annex which is supposed to be the new
dwelling
next slide please
and here's just another image to show
show them an angle of that
um of the existing cool things are built
for
next slide
here shows the proposed site plan with
their indicative boundary to separate to
into individual properties
outside here is the principal Innovation
that shows the main dwelling with the
chain in its current form with internal
Renovations but in even internal will
retain its original or current layout
and the proposed new dwelling will
replace the existing flat roof garage at
the front of the property uh with those
Flatwoods extension as shown
here is the proposed rear elevation uh
with regards the new dwelling where the
annex is that will replace the four
Conservatory elements and that will be
the only aspect to that it will also
remove the existing that with a link
between both properties and replace of
these to move one main dwelling where
there's severe damage
water Ingress
there is a Riverside Innovation to the
front and then the side elevation of the
code is dwelling
is uh the other side innovations that
proposed for breakdowns
and probably beneficial which though
existing ground floor plan of all those
built form
and next slide please will show you the
composed
um
the existing first floor layouts
and this then showed you the page now
the main consideration is the distance
is the principal development and it has
detailed indexes report the local plan
doesn't provide a provision for such
such division in the countryside however
we were then developed to the mppf and
graph AGB through sets which allows
dwellings in such locations and composed
to subdivision and in this instance
firstly in principal terms does the
existing
um
broad space capable of functioning S2
independent waves in this instance
in a nine-bedroom property
exactly we look at to make sure with the
proposed new dwelling the ministry and
empty area or to existing barrier and
it's innocence it's considered abandoned
and there's a sufficient provision of a
proportion of provision of private
immunity space to serve both dwellings
independently
um and furthermore is noted with the
consultation that's um
there was concerns regarding this as
extensive Works proposed because there
is an area of a substantial rebuilding
to replace the black roof elements out
in front of the annex however there's a
substantial amount of existing Annex
being retained and in its own right the
floor space associated with that would
be capable of functioning as an
independent Australian in terms of
National Space standards that therefore
the proposed extension to that the 10
male member of the built form was
considered proportionate and appropriate
turn into the character and appearance
and the impact on the other designated
Heritage assets so during the
consultation it came to light through
the Town Council and the injectors as
well we have a conservation officer that
is building that required represents a
local
um Heritage value therefore subsequently
reacted into negotiations with the
applicant to provide an appropriate
Heritage statement to allow us to
identify for them to demonstrate what
looking features are of the building and
our board to inform the design and
subsequently we eventually get to a
position whereby the main dwelling of
the key features entertained in this
common form and then the proposed
building Works to the annex and the
proposed new brain that's exhibit in its
own are sympathetic in keeping with the
the site as a whole
and therefore the objection was removed
from the conservation officer in the
senses
um medium packed beyond the site as a
whole it's considered there wouldn't be
any significant Community arm it was
noted that through construction and
deliveries that could be noise
disturbance however it was the wreck
then did that that condition institutely
mitigate that harm in terms of hours of
construction and deliveries rather than
to impact it was noted that there was
concerns regarding the bowel drainage in
this instance is proposed to utilize the
existing power drainage at sites and
informative one I believe informs the
applicant should there need to be
changes to that subsequent lead that was
required planning position that same
right and prepared to notify the Council
of of such such changes to the power
drainage
um highways it's two parts to highway so
standing advised with the bride in this
instance with respect to the vehicle
access or into the bloody Corner
um and conservative Ranger guys and
passing places and so on but in terms of
the officer's recommendation the
existing brain is obviously substantial
sort is that could
um about to a number of vehicle
movements arising from the property as
it stands therefore in terms of the new
dwelling being proposed as a part of the
scheme that's considered on balance it
would be in the additional vehicle
movement
um conservative rays of guiding the
public footpath and the public rights
away officer was consultant and
considered there would be a significant
harm to users of the public the path and
the silver more common advice
to make sure there's no obstruction for
that the park as a result of being
development of the site ecology that has
been mitigated accordingly the only
other matter to raise
um subsequently
and their comments received regarding
restricting permitted development rights
for both properties and the office of
this report it was considered it would
be reasonably necessary only the six
tests of the plan and commission to
impose such restrictions in this
instance as such it's recommended the
application has been
recommended for approval thank you Jeff
thank you Angela for that we've got
three speakers for this
application the first one is councilor
Peter Haynes speaking the northern
Parish Council
Angel
you've got three minutes to address the
committee
we are pleased the applicant has agreed
to retain the windows at both Tides thus
helping to protect the House's
historical significance however those
concerns in future on the committee
development rights the windows and other
features could be removed even if
planning permission permission is
granted the revised application before
you it's therefore strongly suggested or
withdrawal of committee development
rights is sought and also listed status
assumed this action is given Force by
the detailed evidence of the
conservation officer and a member of the
public about the historical importance
of the house including its associations
with a nationally important author
although it is suggested this evidence
should have been provided in a
comprehensive Heritage statement as
required on the local plan policy dno 7.
floor them is also concerned about a
major ambiguity in the development
proposal the application refers to the
separation and alteration of the
existing planning Institute weddings and
yet your officer refers to subdivision
of the existing house and appears to
interpret this as a meaning separation
the officer bases its recommendation to
improve the occupation mainly or Clause
D under paragraph 80 of the framework
which allows the house in Oakland
Countryside to be subdivided however its
northern councils and objects as good as
subdivided in the policies intended to
mean a division within an existing
structure in order to make separate
areas of accommodation rather than us in
this application physically separating
and modifying the section of the house
through demolition to creative dwellings
we therefore argue the applications not
should not be approved because of the
post-creation of two dwellings would go
against the intention of paragraph 80d
also by interpreting the policy in this
way and approving the application all
Council will be setting a precedent for
other similar proposed developments in
the countryside
we also accommend that by creating two
quellings of bow tie there would be a
conflict with local bound policy s207
which is designed to prevent new
prevents new developments in the open
Countryside in less local economic and
social needs to be shown or a need to be
at the countryside reasons which
certainly don't apply in this case
you've got your officer further adjust
device physical separation into two
dwellings by stating this will improve
the built form the main part of the
existing house
we suggest this is not only debatable
but primarily not a reason to overall
paragraph entity or st07 the applicant's
original proposal to remove historical
features of the house is evidence that
the application is not driven by
aesthetic considerations to improve to
build pool
finally we agree with residents concerns
that the development or leads are an
unacceptable and hazardous traffic
impact on the access road when Vehicles
based of the two dwellings Zone from
deliveries service vehicles
the road is only single track or the
track is only single track and lacks
passing places and is also a public
right-of-way which is used daily by
Walkers and joggers who will be
extremely vulnerable vulnerable to the
increased traffic and actually to wind
up now he's easily up please no LP
policies dmo4 and dmo5 apply here given
our concerns to Northern Town Council
strongly recommends refuse of the
application and it also to protect
historical significance of bow tied and
it's requested the removal of
development rights and listed status are
assume thank you thank you
our next next speaker to this
application is Keith goodread a member
of the public speaking accounts now yeah
we'll bring in the second speaker Sarah
Mendoza then speaking against
and once you're settled you've got three
minutes to address the committee event
years
hi good morning everyone
um
I'm speaking uh I'm actually Nick Arnold
today
[Music]
um
Nick can't be here this morning so I'm
speaking on his behalf Nick Arnold is a
local author and historian
um based in Apple Store you and control
you are aware I am
um so I wonder how many of you have
heard of Charles Garvis perhaps you
should know about him because he lived
in boatenide in 1911 the times called
Charles Garvis the world's best-selling
author the dictionary of national
biography calls him a publishing
phenomenon he was the JK Rowling of the
1900s
and you can see his photo here Charles
Garvis wrote over 150 at romantic novels
he was a leading figure in UK literary
circles
his famous author friend W Somerset
Moore said I'm convinced that when he
sat down to turn out another of his
innumerable books he wrote as one
inspired with all his heart and soul
Charles garbage lived in a boat Town
hide for over 30 years his youngest son
basil was born in boat ride in 1885.
Charles Garvis was a Northern Town
councilor and County councilor for devil
until his death in 1920. it's quite
clear from his books that Charles Garvis
loved the Devon Countryside and was
inspired by his home at bow tied and
it's also quite clear that Charles
Garvis is of national importance and so
is bow tied
any application for spot listing go time
will be successful
because the government revised principle
of selection paragraph 13 but it too
Estates to be able to justify special
historic interests a building must have
closely substantiated historical
associations with nationally informed
individuals
even as an undesignated asset boat hide
must be rigorously assessed under
National planning policy framework 203
which requires a balanced judgment in
terms of scale upon the significance of
the asset
the application proposed demolition of a
Gable and other harmful alterations to
the west elevation of the main house
which is demonstrable National
importance we're still permitted
National sorry development rights would
allow more horrendous damage in the
future
clearly this application conflicts with
national planning policy framework 203
and therefore conflicts with your own
policies dmo7 and sd15 as you know both
policies Place great weight on the
conservation of Heritage assets
um so Nick says you have two choices to
do something wonderful for our one our
national literary Heritage and local
tourism you refuse this application on
Heritage grounds a site dm07
st15 and nppf 203 or you postpone voting
until a proper assessment is made of the
building's historical significance as
required by policy dm07
your officers to reassess the
application and for the applicant to see
listed building content thank you very
much indeed thank you
but our next speaker against is Keith
Goodwin a member of the public speaking
against the application
um
foreign
[Music]
good morning councilors today I'm also
speaking on behalf of President Ecuador
residence Association
this application is being considered on
the basis that is in the subdivision the
single dwelling or two dwellings in
accordance with national planning
quality framework this is incorrect
because of the extensive nature of the
world if necessary to create two
separate ones in reality it is a partial
but substantial rebuild to create an
additional dwelling in the country's
Soul if the current proposal was
considered as a subdivision it was set
to the president in similar projects and
redefine the meaning of subdivision it
should only apply to internal Union
number property without substantially
affecting the size and appearance of the
original ability
this this I believe is supported by Play
Store and common practice with other
local authorities
have a new dwelling in the countryside
medical plan policy st07 applies
it restricts such people learning to
that which is necessary to meet local
economic and social needs rural building
reuse and development which has to do
the proposal neither meets these
criteria nor is it a sustainable
location and is therefore country to
both local plan and mpps policies access
to the proposed dwellings lies at the
end of an approximately 800 meter yes
that's half a mile of poorly surface
single carriageway track with no proper
passing places
the nearest public transport link was on
the a386 residents will rely heavily on
the use of the car for access to public
and private services
this would be the case even if it were a
subdivision
the composers will result in potentially
double the number of car and service
vehicle trip to and from the site
increasing the instance of conflict
between passing periods the narrow
access track is also a public footpath
and so it could also create additional
conflict with pedestrians along this
very popular recreational route report
proposes the retention of committed
development rights so so at the future
date The Heritage beaches refer to
England report particularly the windows
could be removed or modified or
adversely affected by extensions or race
to secure the future retention of these
very important pieces that the midship
right should be restricted or the
counter it should consider listing the
building there's a lot of people pointed
out Mr nicarno's objection which is not
referred to an implementary report goes
into great detail it's why the original
historic building should be listed he
has carried out considerable research
and concludes that boat hide meets the
criteria for spot listing I respectfully
request that the application should
either be refused or deferred once the
matters I have raised and have been made
by owners because they are further
considered thank you very much
thank you Mr Goose we've finished spot
on time
thank you for that right our final
contributor is from Debbie Newcomb who's
the agent and we read out by Helen in
support of the application good morning
councilors my name is Debbie Newcombe
and I am the planning agent for the
planning application for boat hide the
application is to carry out alterations
to boat hired in order to restore it to
its original state the original dwelling
has been added to over history and at
some point an Annex was created poor
quality building took place linking the
main house to the annex a
pre-application was carried out in 2021
prior to the applicant purchasing the
property the response did not identify
that the property was an undesignated
Heritage asset and we therefore believe
that internal alterations could take
place under permitted development once
the application was submitted the
conservation officer and Northern Town
Council recognized the importance as an
undesignated Heritage aspect the
applicant then commissioned Southwest
archeology to carry out an assessment of
the property and its historic features
and prepare a Heritage statement the
report identified key features both
externally and internally the plans were
then amended to fit with the findings of
the report
as shown on the latest plans the facade
facing the river is to be retained with
the original boat-shaped Windows
internally the layout will remain with
existing doors being reused in the
renovation
the application seeks to remove the core
additions which link the two elements
this will allow boat hire to be
renovated and restored there is
currently significant damp in the
dwelling caused by the linking building
the roof in this area is in very poor
condition and allows significant allows
a significant rainwater into the house
the applicant needs to start work as
soon as possible in order to stop
further deterioration
the dwelling has recently been occupied
by a squatter so security measures have
had to be put in place the property has
been neglected for a number of years and
was lived in by an elderly gentleman who
passed away during the sale of the
property the second part of the project
is to remove the link building to the
annex to create a separate dwelling this
will be extended in a sympathetic way in
order to not detract from the main house
the large Garden area can easily be
separated to create two private amenity
areas the total floor area of the
property as a whole is not that
different to that proposed rather than
creating an eight bed property within
the existing belt built form it is
considered more beneficial to create two
four bedroom drawings the applicant is
in discussions with Devon County Council
public rights of way regarding the
access to boat hide and he will be
carrying out necessary repairs and no
point will construction traffic be
blocking the public right-of-way are
there as there is adequate space to the
front of boat hide for parking the
access road had been and will continue
to be used by the occupiers of boat hide
as it is the only means of reaching the
property
we have engaged with the council's
conservation officer and planning
officer throughout the application
process providing revised plans and a
Heritage report in order to address the
initial concerns and as can be seen by
the officer recommendation of approval
the scheme is compliant with all local
plan policies
thank you Helen that includes the
contribution to to this application that
if anybody would like to start the
discussion on it
some questions share if you'd like to
come forward to the microphone please
[Music]
can you just reiterate your reasons why
the property should not be listed
and if Angelo could kindly put up the
nice Arrow photograph for me
next one
that one yeah
um what you can see in this aerial
photograph is you can see a range of a
roof ridge running facing the river that
I think is the earliest part of the
building with the nice windows and then
the building has been added to at right
hand
Victorian piece and then at some point
effectively a 1930s Bungalow has been
tacked on the higher ground
and it has been linked by various I mean
as you can see there's just like a
little rigid room that goes back between
the two
um the garaging the 1930s garaging
facility you can see with a flat roof
and an arch and another little garage to
the side so those have just been sort of
added on into war so my take on this is
about the most important bit is the sort
of L-shaped roof based in the front and
the
and the um Victorian piece now initially
those were going to be substantially
changed and the ring layouts changed
what has happened is after the Heritage
assessment is being carried out the art
happened just completely changed the
plans that part is not changing
um the Riverside will remain the
L-shaped piece will remain and the
internal links will be
the only thing that will be changed is
that the link between the 1930s bunker
at all
um which you can see is a sort of flat
roof bit that then goes into a hip to
bed that will be cut off and that will
then separate the two units they've
they've effectively functioned as two
units then the name plate on the gate
says vote High Down The Moorings I've
been run down by a nice lady in a yellow
Metro several times that she nipped up
to the end of the road to pick up a post
and she was the carer for the gentleman
in the main house so
um from my point of view the plans we
have before are Stone harm the historic
part of the building it isn't listed
it's come forward as part of the
application process and the applicant
has listened to what we've asked and has
changed the plans accordingly
okay thank you
well from my point of view I thought
when we had the site visit and then we
saw the presentation
that this is an improvement for me on on
what was there I think that flat roof of
connection of the 1930s Annex Building
is awful and and the pictures that we've
seen have changes to the garage at the
front and the separation actually
improved and prove it and for lobster
has just said no uh the applicants have
obviously listened to the advice from
the conservation officer and the
original
section that faces the river and the
L-shaped piece that's a Victorian
Edition and not to be altered inside as
perhaps originally the purchaser of the
building would have been tended but to
separate that bungalow
I can't see where the extra traffic is
going to be generated because whoever's
in there now who nearly runs there over
lives in it and uses that road in Access
so I got no problem I think it I think
it's a vast Improvement what we've heard
about the it's an unlisted Heritage
asset and whether it does become listed
or designated as a Heritage
asset or a separate a separate issue
actually
um and hearing about the author that
lived after 30 years very interesting
maybe somebody will get a blue plaque
onto the front stating them it's an
author I had not heard of but that
doesn't mean anything
um so you know I'm going to move that we
approve this application because that's
one more point question was right he was
about limited development rights
can we not remove those who ensure that
they cannot you know if they stick to
their plans now with the keeping the
front is the same
can we not remove the prevention
development right so they cannot change
that in 50 years so I believe this is
dealt with in the officers report
um National guidance is very clear now
that permitted development right should
only be removed in exception of
circumstances
um often it doesn't meet the condition
tests of being reasonable or necessary
now I I believe the officer deemed in
the in this case that
the property and it's in its wider
existing sense already does benefit from
primitive development right so there's a
question over how reasonable reasonable
it would be to remove them as a
consequence of Business Development I
don't know Angela if you have anything
more to ads
in terms of that consideration and both
Partners were very committed to
development rights to them those new
dwelling and then that wasn't proposed
or is set out an important reason why is
because the site is naturally naturally
constrained as to what could be
facilitated to their independence of
development rights and such any vertical
words can be considered approval
potentially so it wasn't being necessary
for the new dwelling I acknowledge
concerns regarding the historic dwelling
in terms of
seeking the means of preserving the
historic creatures however
Through The Virtuous application
consuming the permitted development in
place it's not considered reasonable or
appropriately necessary to make the
application acceptable to revoke those
rights considering they have them in
place already and maybe Michael's doing
committee aware the applicants put
forward plans that they seem to have
approval form and there will be
conditioned conditions have been
delivered as per those plans
so yeah I I yeah I think that's the
important point I think often and I'm
sure applications that have come before
committee for example the conversion of
a rural building to a dwelling where
you're establishing that residential use
we we often and frequently do when
there's Community Development rights in
those cases but this is already a
residential
um development that already benefits
from those rights and the the
recommendation from the officer is that
it would not meet the test to remove
limited development rights however it is
open to committee to to consider if you
know you disagree with that what I would
say is the national guidance is very
clear that if limited development rights
are to be removed it has to be very
clear which elements of you know what
what it is that you've washed to remove
so
um you know in terms of extensions or
you know the various components of
residential products development one
final Point um the right of way much has
been made about the right way
um and I was thinking examine as an
informative yeah the it um is kept
opened and probably at all times can we
not make that a condition or is an
informative enough
well I think from the agents
um uh contribution that was read out by
Helen been mentioned in there that
there's no intention to obstruct it
right away yeah and I think it's also
important to note there's a separate
legislation and processes governing
public rights of way so were were the
applicants need to
they would have to apply under separate
means so I think on that basis an
informative is because
yeah and mention was made by
um one of the speakers to the mppf and
203 section 203 considering potential
impacts it's only be it says the effect
of an application on the significance of
a non-designated Heritage asset should
be taken into account in determining the
application
in weighing applications that directly
or indirectly affect non-designated
Heritage assets a balanced judgment will
be required having regard to the scale
of any harm or loss and the significance
of the Heritage asset well I don't think
there'll be any loss or
as I said a minute ago I think it would
be Improvement to what's there so
uh I proposed that we do Grant this
application
Council penitence setting in it anybody
else want to mention it councilman God
yeah
um just go back you can't remove the uh
right okay it's fine is there any way we
can Safeguard the
yeah that would be the original section
of the house which is the sea face
that's why with the church Windows you
know as you can see that you know that's
attained I'm good
yeah yeah
I think because that element isn't
changing
um as sort of in our previous response
to councilor Ox query we your offices
don't consider it would be reasonable to
acquire retention of those windows um
because they could be changes things
stand at the moment
um of course if the building were listed
they would need list of building consent
first things stand at the moment being
an undesignated filter just that there's
no protection of those windows
um that would be your officer's
recommendation it all falls within the
same red line so the permission relates
across both it is open to you if that's
what you want to do but our
recommendation would be that it wouldn't
be the test of being reasonable
certainly on the existing dwelling if it
becomes a designated Heritage I just
became listed then any any changes would
require permission that was my second
question but obviously his garage is now
today then in future he becomes a
listed property what happens then
so so at the point of it being listed
then any work to the windows that you're
discussing then that would need list of
building consent and certain planning
permissions that we wouldn't need at the
moment because of the nature of
permitted development to certain things
that a dwelling can you can do to a
dwelling um that's not listed under
permitted development but if it's if
it's a listed building then that's
restricted so the nature of committed
development will change in any works
both internal and external on the whole
would require listed building concerns
another issue well I don't think that's
an issue I've spent about 12 years at
this property every day for my mom I've
obviously worked there but for the
original owners at the time I don't need
any interest there because obviously so
many hands has gone through but I spent
about 12 years at this property that's
mainly sweeping that really leaves off
that finish
schooling but no I spent a lot of fun
down there but I've just it's something
to me it is like an Heritage asset
that's my best opinion
that is boat lines I mean and when you
look at those little Windows there I
mean I I suppose there's a charge
they're getting a little castle you know
there's either catch a good fault there
and I just love to see being practice
Taurus trying to keep me keeping that
one section of that property what a lot
of wrestle is it's all about the rest of
it it's equally biggity basically lives
around we're building a building there
but it's just that main just something
destroying the condition I'm going to
try and keep those windows and that main
facade they're facing the seaside
section
right but it's been moved to approve by
myself secondly by Council Pennington
tickets
I guess it's whether the recommendation
will include removal of PD rights is
that what your what is regarding the
windows yeah
it's been recognized that composite of
that features and their order plans I've
taken that into account to retain them
as per the planning permission but
serves and beyond that that is a
question to discuss if you want a
committed development rights to revoke
that's it yeah yeah right and absolutely
foreign
[Music]
everybody
chemical civil please
to grab this application
go against
that's the Pennington or
Bachelor
thank you
thank you
we move on to our next application
application e
thank you everybody if you're leaving
could you please me thank you
sure just to be clear
before the starts I do believe the
virtual site visits after Helm sent me
the link but the law is
see stuff and I only saw the date for
about 10 minutes and probably my
computer at home but I've been saying
you were talking about moving around the
site so I have seen that I've been for
the broken site because if I don't think
I have it as fully as
um because Lauren's Supreme stuff online
will I watch it independently thanks
cancer Paddington right we move on then
now to application 70 which is a change
of use to security dog exercise area and
Laura you're giving us this presentation
thank you um yes thank you Jeff uh so
the applications for the change of views
of the land to provide the dog exercise
area uh or maybe another Stone access
track and a hard standing long filter
agents to the existing roadside access
you can move on to the next side please
so the application site is located on
the south side of winterland Lane
which it surface to the sailing
holdsworthy
um so error photograph showing the site
in contact with surroundings we've got
the house of Holland Park Farm to kind
of almost immediately to the north
northwest of uh
squared occasion site there and then
we've got tasty Frost house which is
throw them to the north west to the west
side of the access track and then we've
got agriculture buildings to the north
as well we've been associated with
Holland Park bum
foreign
site plan shows the dog exercise area
which is the square red area bottom pan
and then the access crack running south
from Richmond Lane outloaded red there
and then the Alternatives of visibility
display onto winter and later that will
be part of the side
but photographs here and viewing Sarah
belonging access road practice tracked
down across the application site once it
slopes down from the north to the South
and then we've got these north towards
the proposed access track so run along
the Hedge area on the left hand side the
photographs and then there's the
existing field access gate
and the review from the application site
back to the main house at Holland Park
Farm
and then use either direction along
winterland Lane convenient ideas to the
highway conditions on this section of
the parade
to move on to pay site plan so we've got
in the gray sorry the dotted lines
indicate where the posting around
fencing would be to provide the secure
job Paddock uh the gray Square the
corner indicates where the parking area
would be for two cars along with a
relevant turning space and red line
indicating the access track line
and then propose to access arrangements
to the northern part of the site
um which have been better to discuss
with the county council's highways
officer and this indicates
um the proposed widened access
and and with plants as indicated in the
purple rectangle sir to direct traffic
legal site to turn left
and then use tasty Lane as an
alternative exit route rather needing to
exit from Renton and Lane back onto the
a388 and also read the indicator they're
a very small red squares are um traffic
flow plates also to encourage
um vehicles to exit and to turn left so
all those Works would be within the
applicant site rather than on the public
Highway
removal's material considerations uh the
principle of the development will be
supported by policy st07 I like the
brand considered to be appropriate in
the rural area and to meet a local
social need
and submit the design an access
statement indicates that there is a
demand within the local area for such a
facility and the popularity of other
similar facilities
and the impact on character and
appearance and the main works on site
would relate to the access and the
visibility displays at the entrance and
we have a stone access track and then
we'd have stopped fencing perform the
dog Paddock and due to the nature of
these Works no harm and impact is
considered to result on its surrounding
landscape
in terms of
transaction amenities and neighboring
tasty cross house to the Northwest was
over 170 meters from the airport
proposed don't go through Paddock and
we've got over 300 meters to the nearest
neighboring property to the north it's
not consideration result and harmful
impact on organizing management
amenities
Wheels have conditions restricting the
hours of use and the number of dogs as
well which has been recommended by the
Environmental Protection Officer
in terms of access and parking and as
we've seen there's a wider visibility
display and additional features doing
encourage a one-way system for our
vehicles entering a neck from the site
and the county council's High rates
officer confirm that they've got no
objections subjects in the relevant
conditions to ensure that vehicle is X
to the site turn left only
and in addition parking spaces and
taking place would be on the site
in terms of ecology uh Hydro assessment
report has been submitted in relation to
the section of hedge bank which would
need to be translocated to provide the
visibility display this includes
management works and amended statements
but this survey has not identified any
potential harm on protective species or
their habitats uh there are conclusion
the proposed development is considered
to be in keeping with the relevant
policies of the local plan
and the application is recommended for
approval thank you chairman thank you
Laura we've got three contributors to
this application the first one
speaking in support is Frederick horn it
is here yeah if you'd like to come up to
the microphone speak right in for the
end of it thank you yeah and once you
settled you've got three minutes to
address the committee thank you
all right good afternoon and thanks for
uh for your time I'm also speaking on
behalf of Rosemary Barnes It's a
neighborhood of opposite uh the
properties so um you know what are the
the views I'm expressing you know are
her views as well
um we both believe that there's a need
for facility like this in the area
um these days there are many dogs that
cannot be
walked or where it is difficult to walk
within public areas for various reasons
I have one that hasn't previously been
attacked by another dog she is very
fearful of other dogs so and I have to
find areas where I can walk out
where where they're not new stocks that
can run up to her and cause trouble but
also you know young puppies
um that are in training or dogs that
have recovery from injury or illness
often need white areas where they can I
can walk
um currently there's nothing in the
holsworthy area I've done research with
my own purposes and by the places I
could find was roughly 20 to 25 minutes
drive away and also trying to book those
facilities is is difficult you have to
book them off in weeks in advance
um so you know I believe that there's a
definite need back in the area with
facility like this
um and um that doesn't you know need for
this you know having something close by
that I could use and that the other
people in the whole book with the area
of good news
to the community
thank you for your time thank you sir
your contribution Mr
our next speaker in support of the
application is the applicant Rebecca
Porter
and once you're settled you also have
three minutes to address the committee
thank you thank you
um
the previous owner had run the property
as a hobby small holding and in the
current climate it's not economically
liable to run the property purely as a
farming small according hence well
between supplication as a means of
diversification
we intend to stay at a property long
term and we would like to make a
sufficient living from the land we wish
just to provide a quiet safe and
exclusive environment for people to
exercise their dogs
since we purchased the property we've
been renovating it ourselves which
although is taking time and we have
improved the condition and the
appearance of the property many edition
of the dog project will continue to add
to this we've addressed any objections
received from the statutory control
regarding the application so in relation
to highways the access and the embassy
exercise has been ultimately improved to
meet their requests and we've also
agreed to the positions sent back sent
out by the Environmental Protection
Officer and in relation to the opening
hours and the number of dogs on site at
any time
since moving to the property we've
become part of the community and
established good terms with our
neighbors and we will ensure that this
remains which the development is in use
the planning officer has recommended
approval and therefore we do
prospectively requests that the Learning
Community permit the application so that
we can make a viable living
thank you
and finally we've got a statement to be
read out from
board member councilor HEPA who called
this application
um
and just before I started might be
helpful
um as as councilor heple refers to his
calling Reasons by number so it's
probably helped for you to have page 58
of your agenda report opens so
it kind of makes a bit more sense
um
I am unable to attend the planning
committee in person on Thursday 1st of
December but I would ask that the
following submission be read out to all
planning committee members for
consideration in determining this
application
this application was called in By Me on
20 on the 26th of October 2021 at the
request of holdsworthy Hamlet's Parish
Council hhpc five of the six reasons for
that calling are stated in my notice are
considered to be as valid now as they
were then whilst the applicants have
obtained and submitted various reports
that have been uploaded on the planning
portal since the application was the
birth Lodge the concerns of hhpc remain
very much as they were and outlined in
my calling notice referring to the six
reasons for the calling as stated in the
notice I would briefly make the
following observations the committee
members consideration
reason one apparently this appears to
have been addressed by the proposal to
provide hard standing and turning within
the paddock area reasons two and three
these are still material concerns the
hhpc do not feel that they have been
fully and safely addressed in recent
proposals moreover it should be pointed
out that in the planning report to
committee under accessing parking it is
stated that
the final comments received from the
highways officer confirms that they have
no objections subject to the inclusion
of conditions to ensure that vehicle
exiting the site turn left only and to
limit access to the same to those using
the proposed dog exercise area
the most recent submission by the
highways officer of DCC dated 19th of
October that appears on the planning
portal does not State as far as I can
see anywhere that they have no
objections it instead states that the
proposed measures to encourage drivers
to exit turning left only should reduce
the risk of collision at this Junction
that is the wimble Hill Junction where
winterland Lane meets the a388 on the
ground the hill there would appear to be
no legally bindering requirement for
drivers to turn left only and the
measures as shown could prove to be in
themselves dangerous should any driver
exiting the site take it upon themselves
to turn right into the narrowest part of
winterland Lane anyway also as
councilors of hhpc know only too well it
would appear that there is one thing as
it is one thing to attach a condition to
a planning permission and quite another
to see that that condition is enforced
reasons four five and six these remain
real concerns to hhpc
on behalf of hhpc I would respectfully
ask the committee members vote to refuse
this planning application on road safety
and environmental grounds
thank you Helen that's the end of the
contributions to this application
um I have to say when we have the same
result I thought it was a bit
crazy to insist that traffic turns left
point out to this Summit because there's
a lot of properties on winterland Lane
already there obviously can use that
road to access onto a main A380 board
so but there it is that's what's
proposed in there
and I'm going to propose it with Grant
this I think it's a very necessary
um
thing that's needed we've granted one
down at Westwood Hall which has been
well used outside a dog exercise
um if counselor hipples mentioned about
lack of consideration to neighboring
Neighbors in terms of noise dogs barking
how to stop dogs barking then they might
then walk down rental and then back in
their heads off for all you know but
anyway I propose it would Grant this
application
comes with an internet Council Craig and
then cancel that yes my question is
about the business liability if you go
south with only a388 towards uh Colton
um on the left and the right just a mile
down the road after a petrol station on
the left-hand side there is plenty of
dog walking facilities
um through the woods and I'm just wonder
if there's any viability for the
business whatsoever basically
not not really a planning consideration
yeah I mean it it's a proposal for a use
in the countryside
um the the visibility of this is a
successful business I mean
we have to sort of take it that the
applicant has done their research it's
not a use that requires a significant
amount of build development so the costs
of creating the dog walking field I
think it's a slightly different
proposition to a new holiday business or
something along those lines I mean it
may I don't know to what extent
information was it may be the case
topics that can can clarify that
um
is I'm also trying to bring business to
the countryside because I think the
villages need an economic driver I mean
it's clear in the town that we need that
I would have to support that I just
looked at this application in the light
of what is available I I disagree that
one of the speakers said it was 20
minutes or 25 or 30 situations I don't
think well I I know what's around the
area down there
um there is lots of uh or is quite a
large area there walk around the woods
that is available and I I think to leave
it like this yeah I'm a little bit
concerned well if it isn't a successful
Enterprise it won't last
that's a good reason for most of us
going there
again I just wanted to Second your
proposal and I think it's a thing that
is needed
anything it helps to keep small holding
viable than I'm all for it thank you
thank you councilor Brown I was just
going to do well come soon at the time
second ever
I mean as one of the speakers said some
dogs are timid some dogs are recovering
from an illness or injuring not all of
them can relate to go through looking
like that you know I just come from the
chairman yeah just come back we saw the
dog rescue center at Mirage effort and
the rose we had the only very different
with the dogs all the time
um you know I I just see that it's quite
close to a residential area and I do get
concerned when there is better
opportunity as well underway and of
course in the conditions there's only
four jobs at any one time on there I
know councilor heple said how do you
police that there are only four down
there allowing on lots of these things
we we hear from the public if things are
working as as they should do but it's
been proposed by myself seconded by
cancer craigie let me approve the
application could you take the phone
please
come to the fountain
that's good
thanks for Christine or Pastor thank you
oh that's the letter oh
that's in the car four
that's a Pennington surprisingly Ford
thank you
all right we're coming up to three hours
so I'll propose that we go over the
three hours to conclude our business
this morning there's somebody setting up
canceling up Saturday
can you take a vote that we all agree to
that please
can you extend over the three years
councilor Pennington or that's my wife
right we move on that I uh application
7f and the Mary Ellen Moore has taken
this one thank you hope you're working
very long next thing for an application
by the employee of tourist District
Council that's why I've been calling
this morning and it's for alterations
with brothers and capsu areas of science
capacity and advancing things
that makes six film Gardens which you
can see in the plant location thanks to
the South
um and this is mainly alterations
outside the property there is some an
internal operations could you speak into
the mic they could be done under limited
development so we're kind of considering
the external Works maybe this morning
and there's some site photos that's the
front of the property on the Facebook
install
um the neighboring property is the one
at the right hand side so we're
considering this property at the lower
level
um and then the photo at the bottom is
showing you Good Rear Garden of the
property and all these properties are on
a slope so
um there's kind of a void area under the
house in the back
and so the main works on the ground
floor is the relocation of the rear
staircase from the
um adjacent to the property to the
boundary and the creation of a garden
store underneath and then internal
alterations to create a bedroom for the
ground floor
and on the first floor it's to extend
the patio area
and also to create an additional ratio
to the front of the dwelling
um with stairs to see it
and there you can see some elevations in
the proposed changes due to the the
north elevation you can see the moving
of the staircase
and to the Eastern elevation it's kind
of hidden by the wall but there is a new
um access doorway
um on that probation and then on the
middle of an innovation you can see on
the right hand side at the top the new
patio area
and then to the South you can see
um the proposed elevations on the left
hand side is the Apache with the raising
plants is around it
and the change to the front or the
Western Innovation from a window to
patio doors to access the patio area
so that's that's it really so political
development is a minor extension under
gn55 character and appearance it's using
similar materials to existing uh the
main kind of impact on residential
immunity with patio and the front of the
property is only kind of overlooking
parking area and neighboring properties
no change to the highways and parking uh
Wildlife trigger list was submitted
which didn't need an apology report to
be subjected as part of the application
that's it thank you councilor Chris get
there can I start by saying dual-hatid
on my own and I say that because you see
the top page 69 a good photographs might
finally committee on the piano Council
the application is approved
recession
thank you councilor questions
anybody else want to make contribution
no
thank you we'll go to the vote then
proposed by councilor Christie secondly
by Council off
that's about it at four that's the Brown
law
oh
91. thank you all right that's the end
of the applications here
we move on then to item 8 on the project
on your agenda which is the appeals
decision summary on page 72 to 74.
um
move along from that then to now item
nine on the agenda which is cost Sonic
we also at no costs on the fields
item can
uh on page 75 is delegated decisions
agmb decisions there
refused to do that
[Music]
over the page then
planning decisions made between the 20th
of October and the 18th of November
76 77 I'll raise something without you
go through all the numbers chair on a
wider aspect of it 78 page 79
page eight two
eighty-one
82
uh H2 you see the voluntary fuser and
83.
Russell Pennington yeah yeah I find it
very interesting reason to see what gets
from it did not committed us from the
last meeting I um The Voice uh comment
down at the time I just find it very
interested to see you had to listed it
um from the dates that they've actually
been put into the uh um listings and I
see you you're back in the early uh 2018
right at the beginning you go and take
order that's the way you're actually
listing them and I'm interested just as
soon as why assembles are taking four
years and I'm not thinking about
obviously small businesses or get locked
in the process so I'm thinking about
particularly an application that was
validated on the second December
composing which is no one day short of
two years
um and I just want to wonder if we could
not list anything that's longer than 12
months so we can understand where there
is a mock-up in the system of planning
because
there's various issues come across
different businesses along the way and
if we understand why businesses are
having difficulty getting things we
could be more helpful to reward
um to understand to try and get
businesses to go through the situation I
wonder if you would accept a proposal
from me that we actually make another
list that anything has gone past one
year should be listed as undecided at
the Press of forward so I would make
that as a proposal
in a minute from my point of view the
only issue is many of these applications
that take a long period of time
sometimes the request of the applicant
anyway to extend the period of time I
appreciate so
um
we only deal what's put before us as far
as decision making you know and the list
that we read in here of what's been
improved some of them are what we've
approved some of what have been done the
majority spend the delegation well I
think there are many
situation whereby
um various change of the coming I think
the environment bill is still being
going through the college language
um wood burners may become a huge issue
for rural areas and in a few years time
um so some heating for our area might
become most important so environment
agency may be kicking in against Natural
Indian injuries that just take the wood
burner issue that may be coming before
us and and people have wonder how real
difficulty in rural areas where their
natural heating is coming from
um when they're going to have to pay a
huge amount and there's going to be one
government body against another Global
body and the poor applicant is caught in
the middle and that's what I'm concerned
about and where we've built these
applicants that move through pull to
their own and essential stuff is needed
through them to either run a business or
have a dwelling house in the countryside
there is going to be legislation that is
coming down a line to us that will come
before us because one government body is
holding another government body into
Rouse it which appears along the way
like if the wood burner situation which
I fear will be at Oliver again in years
any particular any I mean any member of
the district council and even the 36th
man was or 35 at present who may have in
their Ward
an application that seems to be this up
to them to contact with one in office
and say what's the issue with this is uh
a hold up from our end or is it from the
applicant you know
just a second
yeah
and I mean just just looking at the list
that's on your agenda at the moment I
mean the first four as the Council of
brand knows very well it's all relates
the great torrentine Creamery side and
which is a very unique site in itself
so I think I think that's a quite clear
as to why certain applications take a
long time it's been incredibly complex
multiple land ownership and a long time
to get a legal agreement agreed
um the vast majority of applications
officers are turning around within the
required time scales
our statistics are very good and as
Chris evenly said earlier we the vast
majority we are approving in terms of
percentage of applications that we end
up approving
um it is a high percentage and that I
think that could show how we do try and
work with applicants to deal with
problems find Solutions and it and that
does
often result in things taking longer
legal agreements can cause things to
create longer statutory Consultants
requiring
additional information whether that's
the environment agency whether that's
natural England or indeed Heritage type
comment now it's always open to us as a
council to refuse applications within
eight weeks or 13 weeks just to help
keep things moving but actually that's
not particularly helpful if we can see a
positive outcome further down the line
um I I don't feel it's the role of plans
committee to be monitoring what would be
a quite a significant list of
applications potentially
um we are always there for Ward members
to come and speak to us if there's any
particular application that there is
concern over we're very mindful of
changing legislation as well whether
that's building control related
regulations
um and where we may need to work
especially quickly to get something
through the system as well the
environment bill I think is going I
think it probably won't come into proper
course until November next year
um but yeah I I certainly wouldn't
consider it appropriate to have a list
on the plans commit the agenda
um but we're always happy to discuss
certain applications and see how we can
push them forward but I do think as a
department we we try to find Solutions
and that's that's where sometimes things
stay in the system
I think the officers do give me answers
um when I ask them so it's not a critics
of the officers they sort of trying to
understand how legislation is coming
down the line that is affecting both
yeah domestic businesses yeah and I
think that's something certainly we can
look at as a team and make sure we're as
prepared as we can be around that as
well
I was just going to say the same as the
chair you know there's actual members
that you are made where or you are aware
of yourself and something within your
world then it's up to our school apps
and then you know keep everything on
track I agree with what energel said I
mean a lot of the applications seem to
be held up but section 106 agreements
they seem to take ages to come through
okay approved yes they can do they can
do some do some don't
um it depends on you know we Outsource
them as I think everybody knows at the
moment and it depends on the um the
applicant solicitor as well and sort of
Engagement there but you know it's we
want to get things through the system as
quickly as we can and we do our figure
our figures for dealing with
applications made around
and smaller ones are very good compared
to lots of animals amazing the long list
everybody yes well that is right
everybody thank you I really miss
Captain Pete Watson today because he
always brought immense fires and
creamed certainly
foreign